what's happening you bad [ __ ]
great to see you great to have you in
our heart and [ __ ] joey d is here with
the flying jew steve simone [ __ ]
delivering the goods tonight at midnight
what's the name of the cd remember this
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
remember this [ __ ] i'm available
on itunes tonight don't [ __ ] around
canada russia scandinavia berlin finland
all you [ __ ] we're coming
together like nato
and we're gonna [ __ ] get steve simone
see detonators we're gonna [ __ ] know
what's up with you there johnny weddings
uh
the wedding was fine i had a [ __ ] up
last 24 hours but everything else is
good what do you think what did i tell
you always everything that could happen
goes wrong on those [ __ ] no picking
up cash trips yeah that's why there's no
such thing as a no picking up cash
trippy that's true never again i got a
free stake out of it yeah i gotta
rethink out of it
no [ __ ] miles two thousand dollars a
car a tuxedo you're like a [ __ ]
penguin i look good in there
whenever they come out from the
photographer jesus christ like a [ __ ] i
look good in the tux i don't care what
you say i'm gonna buy one yeah what are
you gonna do with it we're here with the
24-hour fitness damn master [ __ ] sucker
there he is yeah
you should wear tuxedo 24-hour fitness
[ __ ] with people that'd be awesome 30
days
just every day i love it every day just
we'll dry clean it we'll take it to the
chinese guy over here [ __ ] birdbath
remember when [ __ ] chinese people own
dry cleaners yes [ __ ] laundry joints
when i was a kid you bring them t-shirts
like my t-shirts they look like [ __ ]
these gray ones i got 25 of them so you
just throw them away as they go but like
white t-shirts there's nothing more
comfortable yep than a white t-shirt you
got a moustache you gotta you bro
write to the chinese guy
start your underwear fold some boxes
tremendous things like i used to do the
jeans you can't even take the if you
piss you [ __ ] drown in your piss
because you're not going to take your
dick out you got to pull them down
because just
the chinese guys they'll start with that
[ __ ] cotton
that's a crease jack with chinese guys
getting me or what
but uh i used to take out my father my
mom my mom
right on 88th street right down the
stairs around the corner you just
dropped off your [ __ ] that next day and
that that night you came back no ticky
no [ __ ] laundry okay
two dollars if you lose the ticket
everything towels sheets your sheets
smell tremendous they iron your sheets
your pillowcases
[ __ ] everything
everything your t-shirts look like you
know when you take these cotton t-shirts
they're supposed to last a long time
they will unless you smoke dope like me
and you get holes in them and you're
still [ __ ] you know they're white my
grandfather was a dry cleaner for his
entire life you own the drag clown for a
while yeah it's a great [ __ ] i love
them i love the smell of those places me
too i love it now i just don't know how
much my mother has a costume when i was
a kid what's that i don't know how much
it's supposed to cost against dry
clothing four dollars for like a nice
shirt you know to keep it they charge 14
for the suit is that did i get ripped
off no that's it that's what it cost
that's 14 and they take the stanza and
they take that ass smell out of your
[ __ ] jeans oh my god and you leave
your jeans look nice they iron them with
you know it's nice it's a different life
you know it's you got to have time to
like here it's an hour out of your day
to drop off closer close
so that's it you know somewhere else
like new york city you could go right
down the river
so it's that's the differences i don't
want people to think that you know it's
just the differences you know yeah i
miss all that [ __ ] just dropping [ __ ]
off i still drop it off because it's
just
it was more for when i had a full-time
day job i just didn't want to spend the
day during my own like only two days off
doing it yeah but now i found a place
over here that does it for a dollar a
pound
i'm like why am i gonna spend all day
your underwear yeah what if you have a
nice skid [ __ ] mark in there which i
know you do you disgust sometimes i have
to make a decision sometimes i'm like am
i gonna put this in am i gonna throw
this away you don't spray shot in those
[ __ ] panties he goes
no it's got skidmark and ball sweat
almost all my underwear are dark colors
you got that yellow juice wet that
cringes around the nutsack and the nuts
that gets hard right you take your
undies off i don't change
and the nuts in the in the cotton ball
like when you take them off you don't
need an athletic cup
you're underwear
because you only [ __ ] bait once a day
that's what i'm trying to tell you only
once a day oh that's right and i know i
know you i know you put those dirty
undies back on no
i know you you
know that's one thing about today look
if you come to my house i have about 30
pairs of underwear because i'll ch i
change at least twice a day that's one
yeah that's one thing because i only i
only do shower once a day but i love
clean underwear it's like when i packed
for this three-day trip i brought like
10 pairs of people
on your nutsack by the yellow and the
underwear
i have dark colored underwear just in
case i haven't seen that dark color [ __ ]
yeah you bad mother this guy is a
[ __ ] evil genius there have been some
times where there's the skidmark's been
too big i just throw it away i'm like i
can't i can't give this to somebody i'm
not a skidmark guy i'm just a pea stain
type of [ __ ] i got the title
neck so it drips
don't you have white keys so do you ever
like have a yellow stain on your game no
i don't wear white gear to that place
because i had a blue ghee that was
perfect
i've been wearing down there and then uh
johnny guerrero's boy and denver gave me
a [ __ ] nice ghee that fits me
perfectly went down there okay i just
pulled it inside my wife my wife just
watched it this morning
nice you hang them up to dry i like my
[ __ ] i went to jiu jitsu again today
my knee feels good that's all i went to
three jiu jitsu last week you know i was
having a hard time
it's it's really weird you gotta uh
you gotta really
be careful of what you wish for you know
when you when you meet a young comic and
they move to l.a
the first thing they say is i gotta get
on the road
you know and i did that when i moved
here i was very fortunate i was in with
john yoder
i was in with the improv and even though
i was featuring some places were
co-headlining me some small companies
were headlining me
i always had work and i would go out for
six months at a time
you know i would go i would leave
november and come back in april and then
leave in may and come back in december
wow i was a [ __ ] savage you were gone
that whole time that whole time i would
just send clothes home to josh wolfe
wow i would send boxes home every like
month i would buy new clothes and once
the bag filled up i would alternate
clothes
underwear throw away socks go to a
walmart that's why walmarts are [ __ ]
the king can you get a wardrobe like
[ __ ] slim jim mcgoot
got a wardrobe on the marshalls you go
to texas you know texas is for fat
people
when you go to houston you go to
marshalls they sell 2x but they're
really 19x
it fits every fat dude you know what i'm
saying like right when you go to 2x here
it's [ __ ] 2x when you go to tennessee
to walmart 2x is a little loose but
pretty much they give you a skinny guy
[ __ ] 2x but in texas you got a 4x you
cut that [ __ ] in half jack
that's going deep that's for a 4x big
black dude with that ball of [ __ ]
phobia that just sits back in his neck
you ever see those big black mexican
dudes in the south texas and they just
eat barbecue on white bread all [ __ ]
day and you know what that is that's
shock that's uh
that chemical when you go into shock
that shoots out of your brain to tell
your body's going to shock when i was
418 pounds i was starting to get that
hump on my back my wife told me she
because you're starting to get and i
watch the tv show about sleep apnea
sleep apnea sends your body into shock
so it releases
come on guys
and it goes and
it packs up behind your spine so that's
one of those big fat guys they live
their bodies are always in [ __ ] shock
at any [ __ ] minute they could drop
once you start getting that fat ball on
the neck there ain't no coming back it's
like you like the dude in the crow there
ain't no coming back when you see those
guys they're six six yeah 500 big
mexican dudes there was a guy in
tucson at bugsies where we used to go to
tucson
the biggest guy you ever saw and he had
those things and i saw him at the store
10 years later he was down at 200 pounds
dog i had a triple stroke heart attack
my leg fell asleep wow he goes he rushed
me to the hospital he goes the deal was
i had to get out and just it was over
like i went from eating 10 burritos for
breakfast to eating
a peanut and a [ __ ] cup of yogurt
like it was over so he dropped 300
pounds
he had a drop 300 before they did the
surgery
yeah that's how big he was well that was
the one good thing about this weekend is
i fit in the seat and i got the the
seatbelt totally fit how stressful is
the situation when you sit on the plane
and you pray to god that the
[ __ ] fits because it depends
some of the new plans would fit me
before right but like the old planes
were like no the old planes i was doing
all the planes fit me this weekend
i fit on a propeller i flew on a
propeller plane today it was [ __ ]
terrifying the plane was shaking
bathroom in the back
i didn't i didn't get up oh i was
[ __ ] i said
that's where they send you now yeah you
cannot get a decent [ __ ] flight like
a direct flight
thursday the 29th i'm trying to fly into
columbus there's only one direct flight
i was telling these guys it's
786 dollars for the first one in america
and then they usually have choice and
something else
first class was 9 800 i was talking to
justin on the phone our friend
the way back first class was 8 600 for
that early flight oh my god because they
only have one direct flight coming from
[ __ ]
from columbus ohio bro they got people
you know why
i'll tell you something for a while
there every time i go to columbus i'd
see people on the plane
the most important guy i'd see on the
planet is the dude from
the office
krazynski the big white dude yeah
krazynski okay he's from ohio from
columbus i flew to columbus maybe three
or four times i've flown with him on the
plane three times he was on the plane
that got on the beef with the guy
one time in columbus on a joe rogan uh
show those guys went in early and i came
in by myself the next day and i got a
beef on a [ __ ] plane with some guy in
front of me what happened yeah we were
eating and he laid all the way back and
i said can you just go up he gave me the
that's the finger
thing he started arguing but he got to
the store this first
so when i got off the cops were waiting
for me oh my god but we smoothed it out
and then i saw him a year later going to
columbus and i go what's up cox sucker
just frozen but it was too late we were
about to get on the plane
and i had been upgraded to first class
and he didn't he was in the [ __ ]
dungeon
it's amazing because i had an issue
where my flag got canceled last night
and i had to drive three hours and then
of course the car rental place charges
you 200 bucks because you're not
dropping off at the same place
it's amazing how we kind of just are
allowing the airlines to do this like if
you cancel the flight or try to change
it they charge you a few hundred bucks
and then the difference and if they
cancel it for no good reason other than
no one bought the ticket we're we're
kind of [ __ ]
it's amazing how we allow that to happen
well we live in some weird times man we
live in some weird times economically
where people um
i'll tell you a couple weeks ago i had
an issue on america when the guy tried
to kill himself in chicago and i knew it
oh yeah i [ __ ] knew it on thursday i
go this is going to be an issue on
sunday and sure enough
saturday night i get that [ __ ] call
that text and they're like hey man
we cancel your flight you know call the
airline right now to reschedule them
like what are you thinking like monday
at three in the afternoon like i can't
do it
they go well uh early morning one out of
the guard i go better yet there's a 5 45
other kennedy
if you could transfer the upgrade for
the first class i'll be there 4 45 and
then he goes done nice i said okay so
they took care of me even though they
canceled the flight so something depends
you know if they
if you uh talk to them correctly or
whatever it's pretty
well you have points i i have no points
anywhere so they kind of just through
they still [ __ ] with you they still i
was talking to my friend robert
and he goes that united changed
everything around in mid game like he
was i'm flying he takes your flight
to monday morning no he takes the sunday
five
from newark and it lands in l.a yeah i
don't [ __ ] know six o'clock seven
o'clock yeah yeah
he's been taking that flight for 10
years he said
and he goes i usually go home twice a
month this guy's a trooper he goes to
[ __ ] jersey on thursday night on a
red eye
gets up [ __ ] parties friday saturday
sees his family that's great gets food
he comes right back on sunday with a
sandwich and the talent calls me up joey
i got an italian whatever
i said he hasn't been home till from may
wow this is the longest because they
raised the plane tickets and they
changed the whole pricing so the
upgrades are gone
so he lost his status he goes i didn't
lose all of it
but i lost because it's now about
spending dollars when you go to get a
plane ticket like today i want to get
american okay american has four prices
listed
they have the base price yep
then they have the base price
if you have to change your flight it's
already covered yep then they have the
base price with the coverage and luggage
fees okay
so instead of paying for you could
travel with two but they'll give you one
for whatever so you save 25 bucks okay
okay and if you cancel within seven days
it's full refundable
you don't lose 100 the way it used to be
it's like turning back the clock right
they always used to give but you got to
pay the full amount yeah you got to go
pay for it now so you're paying like if
i want to pay if the regular ticket was
364
you got to pay
510 to get the special treatment
whatever and then after that first class
is 9 600 to columbus that specific all
the other ones are 1400 that's the first
price i look at not because i'm gonna
buy a first class ticket but that'll
tell you last year the flights to miami
in december were
thousand dollars first class oh my god
do you think just because the people who
buy those are using
expense accounts so like they don't
think that people care i mean who would
buy i mean
if i could pay 12 grand for a plane
ticket that means i could pay the
charter a plane yeah for four of us
probably yeah
i charted a plane one time i didn't
charge it the people i was with
chartered the plane it cost us 250 a
piece
to plot fly from aspen to denver to see
the denver nuggets against the
philadelphia 76ers oh wow december 29th
1983.
dr jay years
moses malone andrew tony that was my
favorite team tremendous
yeah 83 because 84 i was back east so it
was 83 it was the cost is 250
so it was [ __ ] uh 250 a piece we got
the flyer plane the guy let us smoke
dope on the plane
we stayed at some holiday inn in denver
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] uh hotel people were
yelling and screaming we were told
that's where the nugget party was going
to be at afterwards
that's why we checked into that hotel
that was [ __ ] they were just trying
to get you they were just trying to get
us in there was nobody [ __ ] there
that's hysterical what's up steve simone
i'm loving life joey steve simone how
long have you been doing comedy uh 14
years full time was this your first cd
yep
first ever yep first debut everything
it's amazing it took me about [ __ ] 14
12 years to do something right my first
cd was [ __ ] horrendous i hear yours
is [ __ ] tremendous i'm proud of it
lee worked really hard on it makes me
sound good he's a [ __ ] animal so i
didn't i honestly didn't do much i
it
was a lot of fun to work on but no i
didn't i cut out a couple stuff but no
it was me it was it's basically your set
it's great lee's a fan
which makes the editing process a lot
easier
when somebody doesn't know you you know
there's so many variations of doing a cd
and that's why so many people get the
finished result and go what what
yep because first of all they didn't sit
in the studio with the cat yep at least
you had a relationship with him he knew
your material going in he knew your
timing yeah he liked a lot of the bits
makes all the difference in the world
what makes all the difference in the
world
so 14 years
what is your first
cd about what
it's uh just about it's similar to my
podcast about looking back at the good
times
and it's just about who i was as a kid
and why i'm talking about that now you
know like just focusing
it's about that choice of focusing on
what sucks in life or what's good in
life and uh
i'm done focusing on what sucks and i'm
just trying to
enjoy life so i open up with a bit about
chinese food how it's the greatest and
how it puts me in a good mood whenever i
eat it and then boom and then i started
somebody's chinese food last night
somebody in san diego took your chinese
no some one of my buddies my buddy uh
my buddy art arturo him and his they
come out and see me whenever i'm in brea
and they pre-ordered the cd and the
celebrate they ordered chinese food so
he sent me a picture looked fantastic
were you raised rich no
no i think that's probably why middle
class
yeah that's probably why food's a big
deal to me because that was the vacation
we could afford you know paycheck comes
in friday night was pizza night that was
a big deal just to have like to go out
and sit down and have pepperoni and sit
down miss pac-man oh yeah that's the
best i asked if you were
born rich because one of the things i
feel i have in common with you that
we've always had in common
has been our childhood yeah you know
it's really weird that i lost my mother
at 15.
and that would make my childhood bad
but it really didn't that was one
of the many stories you know when we
first started the church about three
months and i got a really
uh hurtful email
somebody sent me an email an email and
said you know i tried to listen to your
[ __ ] thing but i thought it was going
to be about social politics or whatever
it's called the church or what's
happened now when you talk about your
past
and i wanted to describe to people my
past because that's what molds you
absolutely that's what makes you say the
[ __ ] that comes out of my mouth when me
and leah alone or we're getting in here
or whatever
it's so weird how i
i had a really good time growing up like
there's times at night i catch myself
giggling yeah something stupid of
my friend roger or um
when i talked to you you're one of the
few people that really
had a [ __ ] good time growing up you
caught the tail end of kids in your blog
absolutely people's houses wrestling
breaking a window yeah getting in
trouble not with the police
but it was there's a different type of
trouble there's police trouble like
you're a stupid [ __ ] at 12 right
because i never had police contact when
i was [ __ ] 18 or something 16. for a
fight or something but before that there
was no reason for police contact unless
you drew an egg what the [ __ ] are the
cops going to do you're not going to
arrest yourself
they're going to chase you down and make
you get against the wall and you got to
piss your pants and you really find let
you know what kids already [ __ ] [ __ ]
growing up he did it he made me do it
that kid is done the next day like he's
he has to transfer school
if he grew up in my neighborhood like
that's it like you had a that really let
you know what kids were punks or yeah
whatever so
i cherish
my childhood i look at my daughter and i
go i hope that
she laughs a half as much as i did
growing up because that's what it means
to be a kid it's everything and that's
what it means to when you're 30 and
you're [ __ ] in a [ __ ] job and you're
in a [ __ ] relationship on the bus on the
way home yeah you think of that time
with your brother when you hit him in
the head with the light
exactly and he got stitches and he
bandaged him up and talked him out of
yelling for mom exactly hit me now hit
me now oh god
and that's that's that controls almost
worse like when your mom is gonna get
mad or like wait till your dad gets home
i used to do that all the time you hit
me you can hit me and you know and then
it's fine and then and then let's even
it out let's settle it before the
authorities are involved and that's the
great thing about uh your cd is
the the jokes are funny
but like during it you like during the
chinese food bit
i'm listening but i'm also remembering
me going to chinese chinese food and my
dad being like stop playing with your
chopsticks yeah stop fighting and then
and then the poo-poo platter it just
it's all the best stuff in life yeah you
don't need a million dollars to have a
good time like i think that's the whole
[ __ ] of this city and i go it's not
where you are to your with and it's the
little things in life and
you know
to me
the best stuff in life it's it's it's
your relationships it's who you're
friends with you becomes your family and
then the good times you share with them
that's it everything else comes and goes
doesn't matter what you drive what you
wear it's all [ __ ] but like this
right now it's the most fun ever we're
just hanging out what's there's nothing
better than that when i was in miami one
of my buddies showed up and we started
talking [ __ ] he was asking me if i
remember the day
when i went to mckinley school to
grammar school i had three hangouts i
had my mother's bar that neighborhood
with those kids i hung out with the kids
on 26th street projects in north bergen
they hung out with the kids by my house
on 38th street the projects were a step
down but that was always good action
lots of laughs there was always [ __ ]
good [ __ ] action what is action like
fights or action is action there's [ __ ]
going on life it's happening it's
happening yeah like these kids had fun
yeah so alberto ali had a brother a
great name
cuban kid
and it was really ale it was spelled to
ale
juan only had a brother alberto ali
juana lee was the brains of the
operation
alberto was just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like he was but he was a sweetheart yeah
but you could tell this kid was going to
struggle in life he just
he just had a permanent smile you could
hit him in the head he was pinky and he
had a permanent smile like yeah he's
pinkies
and one was when i hooked up with them
one was probably 13
and alberta was probably 11 and uh and
juan was going to hook her houses
at 13 and taking alberto with him
oh my god and they would tell me the
stories and alberto's face would turn
around and he just gave her yeah she she
sucked it and she washed my dick with a
butt it was [ __ ] classy
absolutely they lived next to uh mole
manny
and joe pep pepper boys across the
street bowman and jack so that's that's
always action because you're try to
shoplift
somebody leaves a [ __ ] tool out what
would a little kid steal from pep boys
you don't have a car a wrench it don't
matter it was the thrill it was the
thrill thank you it doesn't matter if
you steal a tire that's flat
that's your
it's going to last a couple of days it's
[ __ ] flat
uh
and there was a place next to it that
i'll never forget i cherish i [ __ ]
love this place and i wish every kid
lived next to this place it was called
duratest
and they made light bulbs but they made
those light bulbs right there you see
those like the long skinny fluorescent
ones i have no idea what war is
happening
because nothing could happen to
the glass breaks just by tapping the
shell
but there's a white powder in it that
just releases that's it all those
[ __ ] got cancer today all those
[ __ ] steal light bulbs and hit
each other with them so they dump them
in the garbage can
weapons so at [ __ ] 501
alberto jumped the fence i bent though
in the back lincoln and alberto would
jump to the top
and he would jump defend barbed wire
alarms and [ __ ] he didn't give a [ __ ]
and they would start handing over these
things we take you know you could carry
10 of them each
we take them put them down you're ready
and we just go to [ __ ] sword fights
with each other sometimes they were
three feet long sometimes they was six
feet long and you just smashed each
other awesome but they also had light
bulbs
right they also clear the pop so what
you did was you figured out a way to
snap the top a little bit and you could
unscrew
the top and one day i took a rock
like a little rock and put it in there
and i put it i just wanted to see what
would happen and i threw it off the roof
and also i had
and i looked over
and i said oh
i
i don't know what it was
i [ __ ] blasted him with this rock
once the the rock was the momentum in
the light bulb and once it hit him in
the [ __ ] head he had like a i don't
know i forget he had a bump like hit him
right here and he had a bumpers bleeding
a little bit but that swallowed up in
the middle was a bus ball around
mixed with blood you got to tell him
it's not that bad
that's not
there was 18 [ __ ] there
and it was me like three guys knew it
was me and that's the best one one of
your friends get hurt
and you want to laugh because it was fun
like you think you just feel down the
stairs or something i'm the worst at
that i laugh whenever anyone falls oh i
have a story with my brother that he'll
tell for the rest of time a babysitter
took us to the movies and i had a big
staircase going up
we look we look we see late old lady
walking up we look away here ah this old
lady fell down all the stairs and i had
to run into my
howling laughing
like other people went to help i was
looking at eight i just started laughing
i had to run away
the last 10 years the best one was when
ralphie may
fell in bert christ's backyard and took
down the [ __ ] kid table with the
chairs the flowers was like a kid's
birthday party or something it was
afterwards that night and they had a
little kid table out there for little
kids and we walked around the route he
walked on that duck took two steps
and just fell to that [ __ ] like a
stunt man he went right to that [ __ ]
table the fall guy and he just laid
there and we went out for you okay and
i'm just holding it it's in my stomach i
can't breathe
i can't do nothing i'm just like huh
huh he gets up he's like that's all
right dude i didn't see it and all this
[ __ ] i paid for it tomorrow everything
he broke the silverware
he broke everything it was like a
[ __ ] bomb in the village
there was nothing but somebody falls but
they don't get hurt that's one of the
best laughs in life yeah but you can't i
couldn't laugh you're not then we got in
front of bert's house he wanted to talk
about his schedule how he's selling
tickets
and i'm dying to laugh
all right wait a minute
i got in the car i made a right-hand
turn another right i had to pull over in
front of jack-in-the-box
i called bert christ and he was laughing
in his living room and i'm like is that
the best thing you ever saw in your life
i remember once i was doing like one of
these [ __ ] events where i was getting
paid a couple hundred bucks to like help
park cars or whatever
and in one of those those events they
always have people that want to be in
charge and they take it way too serious
it's like this is nothing please don't
make a big deal and there's this lady
just giving everybody the business like
walking around making sure everybody was
doing stuff and we weren't working for
her so she couldn't break our balls but
like you could just tell she was
probably a nice person but taking it too
serious like who cares everybody's
making a lot of money for doing nothing
one of those events
so she's given this guy that's getting
paid to stand with us like it's one of
those jobs where
too many
indian chiefs not enough indians nobody
knew what to do so she's giving them the
business from nothing and then she's
walking off she's like doing that
important walk like i don't want to hear
about it you will get it done she took
three steps and fell off the curb like
she wasn't liquid she collapsed her
ankle
and then tried to regain it you can see
the ankle getting swollen and you
couldn't laugh you couldn't laugh and my
buddy looks at me we just looked the
other way
a good 45 seconds she's off in the
distance and he just goes like this
marcy and boom boom
one of the best laughs i've ever had
there's nothing better than laughing man
there's nothing
especially when it takes you by surprise
you don't expect it you don't
i love all that craziness i'll pull over
i don't give a [ __ ] i will [ __ ] pull
over
i laugh by myself so many times when i
get stoned at night all these cookies
and all this [ __ ]
it's for one thing it's to see the devil
yes oh jesus but it's swiped by 9 30.
on the couch by myself
when i lower the volume on the tv the
mute button and just sit there and go
into like
like for the last
month
i've been thinking about punching freddy
when we used to rob the gas station oh
we had a man we had a guy in the gas
station that we'd rob him once a month
um he was half [ __ ] and his wife was
huge
500 pounds huge ankles she wear [ __ ]
heels
and they do coke and he'd eat her ass
and they had a jakku like we went to the
jacuzzi for the night like they were
white trash afraid he was breaking about
the jacuzzi freddie was a sweetheart he
came to monetary listen you could mug me
and when the cops come i'll tell him
that it's a puerto rican guy just
robbed me
so the first time i did and he told me
the cop asked me why i wasn't bleeding
so if you rob me again you gotta make me
bleed i'm like oh don't do this
i'm like i'm gonna cut you
what do you want me to do you know what
is it that you want me to do
and like four gas stations after that we
had like beat him up and i felt bad
after the first time i didn't like
hitting him and that wasn't my bag you
know i had to like deck him and make his
nose bleed
him yeah that's such a great old school
so i asked like of somebody like this is
how much of a [ __ ] i was like
if i have a beef with you i could hit
you yeah but this guy freddie was just a
victim of life he didn't have any harm
in his life except eating that fat [ __ ]
and snorting blow off her titties and
[ __ ] that's it
they had kids they were ugly
i mean he worked
90 hours a week to keep her in [ __ ]
high heels and
you know like beer at night and wine and
[ __ ] and i respected that even at that
age
and i understood and he was such a mower
he would go you know rob the gas station
and anything over buy the eight ball
anything over 500 you could keep give me
at least 500 for robbing me
and i got it you know i got it where
and i didn't care like every time i'd
rob made up like a thousand on them
and i'd tell them they had 900 or
whatever and he was so [ __ ] the poor
guy you know i tried to make two three
hundred and whatever given they bought
whatever
and i would just deck him but i would i
would hire my friends i was such a [ __ ]
i would hide my friends
to tackle him
because i didn't want to hit him i felt
i couldn't do it he was such a read
heart he had no malice in his heart
so i would go hey you and he would look
at me in case the camera was looking i
have a mask on and i get like louis
castellino one of my crazy buddies just
attacking him for the small nickel
like a yard stick a 50 and a couple
lines of blow
a [ __ ] eight ball for a [ __ ]
couple lines of blow in those days you
could get somebody to kill somebody
in the early 80s for a grandma blow i
could get somebody to kill a
[ __ ] if i wanted to i had
soldiers
at my disposal for grandma blow that was
a hundred dollars wow that was a hundred
hard dollars when you're a sophomore in
high school
so i know kids though that's a lot of
money to me now
people who are sophomores and juniors
that would kill a [ __ ] for a
grandma blow and i tell him duck just
come down one time tackle
if you like it i'll cut you on a monthly
level
and they would say are you [ __ ]
serious are you that crazy i had him
i had this other wild guy god blesses so
his name is randy mergle
this white dude was a [ __ ] savage
with clothes on
i know people from north bergen are
listening they remember this guy was a
[ __ ] savage
white trash badass cool as [ __ ] me and
him and roseanne d agastino brother diag
took a bus from new york city to seaside
heights oh i hit a red dragon acid
listening to ac dc
god the bus driver would have to pull
the bus over
and go guys stop with the music one more
time as soon as he sit down
wow oh my god i took him down there to
tackle freddie one time
he almost killed him with a tackle the
kid was like a tremendous football
player i didn't play football for three
years in high school the city he came
out he was he was hurting people wow
because he was just fueled on blow and
rage [ __ ] [ __ ] and lincoln school
lincoln school is where the [ __ ]
the tarts went to school on the third
floor they bring them up in [ __ ]
chains and [ __ ]
when you play them in grammar school
they take them to the games and chains
and
balls on their ankles
lincoln school was this [ __ ] oh my god
you qualified [ __ ] are you going
to lincoln school are you on the third
floor they say because you go by their
desks we'll be flying out the [ __ ]
window oh my god these people were crazy
but the whole area like you had mckinley
kennedy school
kennedy school was predominantly italian
white a couple latinos mckinley school
was a lot more latinos along the crazy
side franklin school was dark yeah that
was on 51st street that was at dark
elementary school i don't even think
they had a gym yeah yes mckinley didn't
have a gym either why no jim no jim they
built them that way you want to play gym
you got to play gym outside oh when it
snowed
you got to be in shoveling
i look like you knew that as a little
kid
and go to the gym outside dog
wow no gym until the eighth grade when i
went to mckinley we didn't have a gym to
practice flat we practice basketball at
the 38th street park outside oh that'd
be so cold but jim outside was awesome
like tackle football in the snow not in
[ __ ] december it wasn't
that ground gets no you're right that
ground gets but there was no grass out
in front oh yeah this is just concrete i
took you there in the front yard i took
them there it wasn't even
awesome and it was wide open it's wide
open there's no building in this
courtyard there's nothing
wow it's a parking lot and downstairs is
where the old gym was the lunch lady and
mrs sabatino i remember my lunch ladies
too every time you look at i should give
you an extra lunch that was the best mrs
sabatino yep
jesus the greatest and look at you know
i still get this is kaluka and and it's
not that i get
i get more nostalgic about this [ __ ]
than when i tell like drug stories about
[ __ ] mugging people and you know but
those things like that like the real
good times yeah you know mckinley and
then you had franklin
lincoln but lincoln covered a vast area
the projects the field
god bless you thank you salud
it covered like a wild area so the kids
in that neighborhood
were a little wilder yeah
robert fulton they were a little bit
nice italian they're a little bit calmer
yeah that was
god bless you
that's my allergies i'm getting
allergies lately
it started about three weeks ago i
thought it was a cold coming on but it's
been allergies i'm making that noise
that's the noise i used to make when i
was a kid
when dogs were uh
you snarl at them i would make that
noise because the hair got caught in my
dancers
[ __ ] go crazy you know one of the
best times you called me high and
laughing was when that radio personality
got lost and you were convinced that and
then the like the president of israel
was coming and you were convinced that
he had the cookie and he called me
already laughing oh my god i ate this
cookie one day and i'm [ __ ] wrecked
in my living room my wife is on the
floor on the computer the baby was a
baby baby i don't even think she was
walking yeah she was not moving because
i was [ __ ] mummified i'm sitting in
this chair
and it was something to do with
casey kasem was lost that week i
couldn't get up to pour on iced tea
like i couldn't get up without him like
this is terrible then they started doing
a report on tv while i was thinking
about the iced tea
about
casey case has been missing
blah blah blah blah blah blah so i'm
sitting there going ooh
maybe casey had one of these cookies
because i know i'm a [ __ ] i'm a
savage and this cookie is making me
[ __ ] go crazy
if a civilian eats this [ __ ] cookie i
can't even imagine what happened to him
so uh and he called me howling and then
he said the president of israel was
coming because he knew about the cookies
and he couldn't even get it out that's
my favorite when you laugh like that one
when you can't even get it out it's the
best kind of laugh that's that's it
that's the best that's right when you
when you make yourself laugh at that
point that's when you know you're on to
a good joke and then that always comes
late at night
or early in the morning you get this
certain clarity
late at night when you've laid down
already and put that on your pillow your
mind slips that's true premise
and a tremendous tag that you got it now
now it's all over you giggle it you work
it out in your head and you work it out
so much in your head
that you kind of wake up and you go you
know what i'm gonna write then you go
why would i i'll remember this in the
morning and ten out of ten times yeah
you don't got it there's no [ __ ] way
i said well it's under my nuts
sometimes you get an x like six eight
inches deep south like you get like a
little ingrown hair i got that today on
the plane but i didn't want to stick my
hand out my pants [ __ ] that i will get
up and shove my hand right down my
[ __ ] pant
and pull out that [ __ ] old air of nut
sock
because once you stick your hand there
you open up your front of your pants
that nut sack rises a little bit you'll
catch it if like your girlfriend's in
the area she'll notice that it smells
like you're nuts like your girlfriend
your wife or something
lee what's going on with you you over
there looking at the [ __ ] ceiling i'm
high you gave me the freaking edible
that you gave me when ari was here
what's the matter you're fine i gave you
10 15 milligrams you should not
the whole thing was 30 lee no it wasn't
i took 20. maybe 12. no
first of all i got half of it second of
all there's no way
i gave you the bottom half i ate the
brains i ate from the ears up it's the
same thing away from the mouth down no
it's not the same thing because the head
was thicker up on [ __ ] top there's a
little chin yeah the head was thicker
but the whole thing was green the cookie
was green
because that's how they do it for
halloween
the [ __ ] it's a new chef the cookie was
delicious gluten-free he's looking after
you
eight calories made with stevia
the [ __ ] you know what i'm saying this
kid's never satisfied he's like judas
priest in the first half
that's a good song that was satisfied
they're on tour
you know ray canel is coming next week
oh yeah my buddy's coming next week and
he was going he was you're not gonna
believe what i'm doing monday
and go tell me because i'm going to see
jesus priest in l.a i'm like oh my god
that's korea
i i've seen judas priest
10 times i couldn't go see him now
i'd feel so out of place and so [ __ ]
old yeah i'd feel hold of the judas
priest concert if i was 30.
yeah and but
everybody will be there be old yeah
those guys are going to be 60. easy
if i'm 51 [ __ ] rob half it's got to
be [ __ ] 60 has to be
how is how is trick-or-treating
trick-or-treating was brilliant i was
with the wizard of oz
no you weren't yes i was i got it mercy
was [ __ ] uh
mercy was [ __ ] doctor my wife was the
witch
what the [ __ ] do you think you're
dealing with some [ __ ] a novice
organization here
huh how did you dress up as a wizard do
you have like a wizard hat had a hat and
a [ __ ] cape how do you think
that's great i think a wizard runs the
[ __ ] show you buy you don't buy me a
cape you don't get like a 201k about the
house
check it out i don't [ __ ] around
oh my god
[ __ ] around jack that's
the cutest picture i've ever posted on
[ __ ] twitter and [ __ ] oh my gosh and
she had these shiny shoes on they were
slippery like the ones i had when i came
from cuba
and i knew she was a gun and she was
going to take a look at the hat i had
see the zombo hat
with the stars oh no i had the episode i
still got it i might drive with it
tomorrow just
go on stage with the [ __ ] cape was
mystical
wearing a cape just gives you this
[ __ ]
it gives you this certain [ __ ] patois
you know that's what people are
[ __ ] don't know the cape gives
you a certain it adds yeah it adds
something to you did you like whip it
around a couple times like with your arm
just like no when you got class and
personality you got at least try it out
i don't need no [ __ ] whipping around
like some half a fruitcake in [ __ ]
transylvania
i'm running this [ __ ] game you know
what i'm saying
[ __ ] these hoes i'm running this [ __ ]
game
i'm not trying to sell the cape the cape
is selling me [ __ ]
not selling the cape we're gonna have a
cape company call us now because that's
the best dad i've ever heard from
you [ __ ] yeah i don't need to sell this
cave the cape's sold the cape sells me
the cape tells them what the [ __ ] is
cracker lacking when somebody sees you
with a cape he thinks two [ __ ] things
this guy's got balls or he's gonna fly
that's it there's no other [ __ ]
ending to that either this guy's got
balls of steel
walking the streets on a friday night
with a [ __ ] cape on
oh he's gonna just zoom by the time i go
get my hands on
that's all where else do you think
when somebody has a cape on hmm anybody
else got any [ __ ] ideas here tonight
i've never seen anyone wear a cape
that's the problem you gotta get out
there more
you're at home you want to go to 24-hour
fitness that's why you got to bust the
first k-pop
you got to bust the cape on the
elliptical right on the ellipse
right next to the fan so it's [ __ ]
tremendous like fabio
and then bust out the tuxedo i would
love to who's better than you
know how much they want to charge you
for this tuxedo there's 200 for the
weekend no for [ __ ] life to go down
there
i have no idea hold them up and say
listen i'm going to come down tomorrow
to check what do you got for me
i want the same [ __ ] tuxedo i got my
nut sweater in it
i [ __ ] in the pants i didn't want to
think about how many people had been
wearing that tux before so you de-fuck
inflammate the [ __ ] deflects it you
take them to the [ __ ] dry cleaner and
say listen some filthy [ __ ] wore these
pants for two years
i want you to take every pubic [ __ ]
hair
listen if csi shows up they don't know
whose [ __ ] was in here that's how
clean i want these [ __ ] pants all
right
csi csi's don't let it go and then go
you know what
we can't decipher the yoda
but by the [ __ ] patois the underwear
mix with the cotton and the [ __ ]
whiff of the pants and the carbon
dioxide levels that's how they blast you
that's [ __ ]
you know i ain't no [ __ ] wizard but i
tell you what actually i photo evidence
you know i'm a fake wizard i went on one
night a year with a hat on big [ __ ]
deal you got to work hard to be a wizard
what if i was walking around with a
freaking wizard hat you'd kill me you
never let me hit the end of it well if
you're walking by yourself with that
listen
listen if you're walking by yourself
down the street with a wizard out again
i'm thinking to myself
either
this motherfucker's got balls or
he knows something he's gonna start
shooting either way i'm gonna leave him
on i could be that could be berkowitz's
cousin he's looking for jonathan's son
you know what i'm saying
maybe jonathan sons and sherman oaks
doing the kettlebell class or something
here i am
dropping around [ __ ] sherman oaks
with the [ __ ] smell of yoko owner on
the car
that [ __ ] kiss of that yoko owner i
can just imagine what would happen if
you put yoko ono and [ __ ] knight
in the same [ __ ] building
there would be a fire martians would
attack
a missile would hit them a [ __ ]
satellite would land on him
there would be a shootout
the [ __ ] triads would show up and
slice her [ __ ] neck finally
why somebody hasn't shot yoko yet is
beyond me you understand me boy john is
dead and buried there's nothing but
bones on the beat alarm some kid slipped
in there
and [ __ ] yoko's still walking around
like some [ __ ] [ __ ]
unbelievable what i got to put up with
what up lisa yet
you're sitting there [ __ ] stoned to
the girls i am
no i had i had something
not weird but i felt bad about myself on
the flight there
two gay guys sat next to me and they
were fine
no no this was on the way back on the
way there
and
it was a red eye so everyone was
sleeping and this one guy went to grab
his
uh boyfriend's hand and he touched my
leg and it would mean i immediately my
first reaction was to get kind of like
freaked out
i kind of felt bad about myself like
like 30 seconds like why like if this
was a straight guy i wouldn't think he
was doing anything if it was a girl i
wouldn't think anything but just because
he was gay like my first reaction was
just like a bad one i felt bad about
myself
well your first reaction they say is
your
best reaction correct yeah the guy touch
you you know you're jewish
you know you're looking at this guy
going this guy's gay he's got some gears
maybe i should sue him
he touched my leg god knows what could
happen
that would have been a good a good plan
i don't know lee i don't know what the
matter will either how many edibles have
you had i don't know does it matter
does it really [ __ ] matter what
edibles i had you're the one that told
me you don't see me getting freaked out
that's [ __ ] uh
you know [ __ ] jolly fly always touch
me
if the guy who sat next to me on the
flight here today sat next to you you'd
[ __ ] make them change your seat you
had a hindu i did was he the gay guy no
no he was just
smelly so where were you in the middle
no i was on that window i always get the
window
on the way there i was in the window and
there are two gay guys to the left of me
so lefty in the same mile yeah and one
of them touched you by mistake yeah and
did you dig it around a little bit
tell me the truth
did your nuts get hard is that why
you're upset
did my nuts actually hard something you
know something must have got
you turned on because you had a feeling
no i it was just a weird first reaction
i don't know which was why you touching
my leg it was like yeah like it just i i
don't even know why i did it like i had
to think about it afterwards i don't
know
i don't know like it's like the same
feeling you get like
like i'm when you see two guys kissing
it's just like it's kind of feels weird
all of a sudden for a second and like it
shouldn't and that's a bad like i have
to work through that
but it's just a reaction it's a like a
just a natural reaction
you know and i just keep walking when i
see two guys holding their hands making
that
i just put my head down say a prayer
keep walking that's all you could do i
don't say a prayer for them i said pray
for myself you know i'm saying [ __ ]
unbelievable but
this is where we've gone what are you
gonna do people are free now right no no
and there's nothing wrong with it like
this
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
i always get gay stories
oh yeah oh yeah and they're the best
they always give you care
they're always in a good mood
do you know a lot of them now since you
fly a lot yeah you see a bunch of them
yeah i meet a lot of people man
it's amazing how you see people and
they're like oh i had you last time yeah
it's cool
you know i'm about to do three more
weeks but
it's funny what i went through about
i uh caught myself the second week of
this last three weekend
and i was burnt out guys
i was [ __ ] burnt out there one week
and then and i knew what it was that i
had had a week off i i did
brea
new york
and then that one week i went to the
[ __ ] races
we probably did two podcasts
uh i did like
a set tuesday and wednesday at the store
and
friday and saturday at the store and
three and [ __ ] long beach that adds
up and i did two podcasts and you know
two jiu jitsu's and the knee surgery and
this and that and
then i went back on the road for a week
and late and i was like oh my god that
week i was home i was supposed to be
wrestling for this three week
and it's week one and i'm [ __ ] dead
yep like i better put this in [ __ ]
overdrive
and then the second week i don't leave
on wednesday and that just [ __ ]
killed me you know that's just and then
the week after that and leave on
wednesday and that's just funny he
killed me again you know you have to fly
on wednesday and take a nap and wake up
there you go travel days are the worst
but the whole thing is you don't want to
fly and then just go right off the into
onto stage
you like to [ __ ] relax in the hotel
room [ __ ] get a bowl of soup some
crackers watch a couple hours of [ __ ]
law and all order i think it's an ebola
soup no i might bowl a sugar together
[ __ ]
and uh you you you know you want time in
between yourself and the comedy you
think about what's happened to
decompress a little bit yeah getting off
the plane taking a shower and going
right to a comedy show
it's [ __ ] horrible yeah it's horrible
your focus will be off that night and
the stress if you missed the flight
so these are the things that uh
but it's crazy that this week when i
came back i had it planned i had the
week off last week and i couldn't wait
because i did two podcasts
we did a live podcast so we did three
but i also only wanted to do comedy two
nights i took friday night off because
of trick or treating but i also find
that friday at three o'clock i'm done
guys mm-hmm friday at three o'clock no
matter where i am there's a point of
solitude where i'm like oh my god
i gotta go out tonight saturday i'm
programmed to go up yeah since i was
three
you're programmed to [ __ ] go out and
friday you should be programmed to go
out but i think after like 37 fridays
were hitting me harder
and harder and harder
and by like [ __ ] four years ago oh my
god
on a friday night at three in the
afternoon i'm [ __ ] done yeah like i'm
done like i don't try to schedule
nothing
you know i mean it was [ __ ] craziness
you got to recharge your batteries you
got to do it you really do and i learned
the balance last week i [ __ ] slept
two days like i
the doctor gave me i had to give me
sleeping pills and that's why i thought
my stress levels were so high yeah
because i was late on and i couldn't
shut the [ __ ] off i don't like that
i stopped the coffee at night even
though the caffeinated done that that
[ __ ] just fueled yeah absolutely no
camera the caffeinated it fuels you so i
go to bed without nothing now [ __ ]
plain clean and sober that's what
and you're back you know what i'm saying
when are you going back to philly what's
going on with that uh
i'll probably go back in december right
before christmas because it's too
expensive to go
for christmas and then i'm on the road
i'm in reno calgary
vegas seattle
i'm going to stay in town for
thanksgiving just because i don't want
to be on a god i don't want to be on a
plane for another week well i'm going to
bring your cookies back because i'm
going the week before oh nice to philly
that plane ticket is [ __ ] expensive
oh my god
but like i told this i owe dubai there
so listen i got bad news for you it's
going to stay like this till january 3rd
then everything's gonna drown because
who the [ __ ] you know we live in times
now that like this week people are
struggling
i went to the weed shop today and i go
no line they're like not this week it's
rent week it's build week yeah this is
dead i was on hollywood boulevard last
night it was like a ghost town ghost
town well everyone knows that there's
thanksgiving
and there's christmas and then
a valentine's day
all within a few months um nobody's
thinking about valentine's day people
are just trying to work people just
trying to put together christmas yeah
right now nobody gives a [ __ ] about
valentine's day they're like [ __ ]
christmas is coming
we're really three weeks away from
thanksgiving i know that's it so you
basically have five weeks to maneuver
in five weeks everything shuts down it
doesn't shut joey what the [ __ ] it shuts
down mentally yeah people already
locking up their year they're accepting
what happened
you know when i gained 18 pounds you
know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna [ __ ] go to that pie place
every day to the 31st and then start
over and then i'm joining [ __ ]
tai chi school and ballet you know
whatever the [ __ ] it is i used to do
that all the time i have like a little
blowout before a diet started and then
the diet and then you you you mess it up
like you have something at midnight the
night before like tomorrow's ruined
i have to wait till i have to wait till
next monday now because i can't start on
the tuesday because that's crazy i used
to make all those excuses
no it's really it's really weird how
that's it once the [ __ ] halloween
holiday passed
by sunday you were already seeing
thanksgiving and christmas commercials
oh yeah i was in cvs on halloween
during the day candy was 50 off and they
were taking it out they used to let it
sit in there for days to blow it out
nope 50 off the christmas decorations
are already up where there was a
scarecrow this is on the 31st they had a
snowman they had santa claus i bought
the m ms that were normally 439 a bag
for a dollar 88. i turned around and the
whole display was gone they were taking
it out on the back
already the crit the christmas stuff is
already up at ralph's it's up at cvs
it's already christmas
it's already that's it and people after
the after the sixth
the eighth you have the christmas party
you got your
cousin's party you got your stomaches
party you got this guy's party eating
cookies that's it in your mind when you
go to work you're there physically
but mentally you're putting together the
[ __ ] recipes and you're putting
together
the pool for the new year's eve game and
all that [ __ ] you know it's amazing
what happens to people when i say
holiday weeks that's why i hate those
monday off because those people only go
to work monday they get enough done to
cover monday
and they know that after that they're on
the computer looking at [ __ ] flannel
shirts we're gonna go fishing how's good
yeah i love beans is it weird for you
guys being out here and not not having
like a snowy christmas because hanukkah
doesn't matter i can never but is it
weird seeing like palm trees during
christmas time for you guys
it was for me at first
yeah it was at first
you guys don't know what christmas is
do you live
in california
especially if you're used to something
i was used to nothing i spent
christmases at bars
i didn't want to go to christmases and
they wouldn't be around people because
it reminded me too much of family
and it hurt too much so i would go
someplace where it wouldn't remind me
we would be at a bar you know those
dingy neighborhood bars in jersey where
the owner cooks lasagna if you're coming
on christmas day yeah i would do that
and watch a football game i may believe
i was interested but i really wasn't
interested
it was six or seven years after my mom
died i didn't want to be around people
opening up presents and
saying i love yous and all that [ __ ] so
i would go to bars but for a guy like
yourself that you celebrated christmases
with people let's face it
christmas out here
sucks
deckley
sucks dick you know you have a
girlfriend now you're going to spend it
with honey you're going to wake up
[ __ ] christmas day and i'll go and
the grandma's going to make your [ __ ]
tamales and [ __ ] and hopefully she'll
get your robe and you get whatever [ __ ]
you're gonna get it
but
don't be a jackoff and get a wedding an
engagement ring no no not for a while
this [ __ ] guy went to a wedding gets
all emotional he's on the phone with
israel
they get very family like twenty two
hundred dollars a year if they don't
touch the [ __ ] hitler payback [ __ ]
they did to black people right black
people sued white people right i don't
think so i don't think there's no
reparations supposed to be
there's reprimands reprimand
reparations yeah so the jews said listen
we want to sue germany for reparations
you know
that's what they should do what are we
talking about we're talking about
christmas christmas that's the stupid
[ __ ] joke
it's amazing you don't know what
loneliness is to
you wake up christmas day here and
you're using that's the worst you got
stole from lasagna in the [ __ ] oven
and you're used to your mother's stuff
and just you know i can't me like i said
for me
it still hurts a little bit i was
telling my wife the other day i looked
at the straight and i go
if i to get you a plane ticket to go
home
do you want to go home and come back
like on the 28th
and spend new years here but go because
it's not about me it's about that baby
yeah i wanted to see snow
i wanted to sit down
on the fireplace what are you going to
do here yeah what are you going to do
here
go to somebody huh i'm over to watch usc
i don't watch us see i want to sit
around and eat some [ __ ] smelts
smelts that's old school christmassy
fish and [ __ ] yeah that's old-school
guinness
you went over the night before you ate
seven fishes
maybe after that i'll drop by lee's
house is that what it was like is it as
a catholic italian thing fish yeah on
christmas eve because my my dad's
friends were were italian catholics and
we went over every year and every year a
different cousin was santa
and like they didn't shave and it was
awesome and they had like meatballs and
ravioli it was the best it was i got
christmas without being christian that
was the most amazing thing ever there's
really no
tightness unless you have mexican
friends yeah that's it that's the
tightness they're the ones that like
maryland today by the way is seven years
of maryland's death i woke up and it's
also rick ramos's birthday
that [ __ ] strokes that's i gotta give
him a call yeah i gotta give him a call
to the poor [ __ ] lady birthday how do
you feel
you go to the movies you gotta put an
extra seat between you and [ __ ]
in case the shooter makes a comeback
cause they're shooting up the movie
looking for batman's cousin
we still got it here on the church of
what's happened now where's [ __ ] tony
bennett [ __ ]
it's a beautiful night here
relax grab some wine do what you need to
do i don't give a [ __ ]
you want to stick around stick around
tonight i know you got [ __ ] to do
two
so
i can't believe someone texted you joey
this [ __ ] savage
they keep texting me for some reason
you know
that's it who the [ __ ] knows anymore
we just show up we eat a cookie and life
goes on you know saying steve simon how
excited are you you call your mom until
you're releasing your first cd on the
yeah i did actually the flying jew label
she loves lee that lee sounds like a
sweetie i'll use the [ __ ]
[ __ ] master disaster look at mizzou
master disaster with a little green
shirt on looking [ __ ] tremendous i
had to take the yarmulke off because my
head was getting too hot
what was in that cookie
oh
death
is what joey would say what are you
gonna do you gotta
you know
you gotta get stoned it's monday night
you're gonna show up here with no
[ __ ] bullets in your gun this [ __ ]
guy goes to a wedding doesn't even bring
a [ __ ] little high for himself to go
to the bathroom eat a gummy bear so he's
goofing on everybody my mom was there
who gives a [ __ ] you go there you sit
next to your mom you'll see [ __ ] you
never saw before
you eat a little [ __ ] gummy bear next
to a little half she'll never notice it
why are your eyes readily i don't know i
got [ __ ] big old [ __ ] onions in my
eyes i don't [ __ ] know what the heck
i'm an adult mom [ __ ] happens what's
with the [ __ ] questions
no more religious pictures no more
religious pages
casino
oh okay right christina goodfellas
goodfellas no more religious pictures
yeah well you gotta eat there you have
ten goomies at the house three pounds of
weed
and you go to a wedding like a [ __ ]
moot well i'm still scared of bringing
it on the plane i got that little thing
on my suitcase your bag has been checked
by tsa
they open it look around and close the
[ __ ] thing for the 80th time
it's i don't know you don't get scared
no what are you scared of
i don't know what are you scared first
of all the gummy bear should be in your
pocket you rip the label right off it
you you eat half of it and you put the
other half right in the [ __ ] security
bucket i had some hard asses in albany
today they made me take my belt off yeah
that's what they do everywhere no but i
i i never take the build yeah they they
patted down the pockets sure you have to
raise your arms so if you have the
grooming in your pocket they [ __ ]
they [ __ ] checked on the armpit
don't [ __ ] with me [ __ ] they made
you raise your armpit and they tickled
you a little bit
you put the gummy right in the [ __ ]
security basket
if you take the label off it just looks
like it just looks like candy you
[ __ ]
why does america make everything tougher
than what the [ __ ] it really is
what do you mean
everybody likes to smuggle it put it
right in front of them
you know
every day people shoot people
and they get caught
the dumbest people were the best hitmen
those italian guys
shot people for years drew them buried
them in the middle of the night
when was the last time you read that
four [ __ ] guys got pinched burying a
body of four in the morning you've never
read that no you go to vegas it's a
thousand bodies buried out there go to
jersey through the meadowlands they're
all bodies those are cemeteries out
there
four people takes to bury somebody you
gotta dig a hole in [ __ ] two hours
that [ __ ] floor is [ __ ] old you
just don't show up with shovels and
everybody just starts
four out of shape people that takes six
hours to bury your [ __ ] body
throw clorox on top of them some [ __ ]
lie
some cement put it water it down put
[ __ ] [ __ ] on top of it
and then bury it nobody finds you have
to mix it in that takes [ __ ] 10 hours
to bury somebody unless you already got
the whole dug
you know so you show up there with the
whole dug
and the body and now but to stand there
with the body for 10 [ __ ] hours in
the trunk of the car while you bur
that's horrible lee
how are we getting on this subject i
have no idea why would you bring this
[ __ ] up
the [ __ ] doesn't matter
we're talking about maryland being dead
ah and now you want to bring this up
it's amazing that maryland
like 10 days before she'd like she died
on
tuesday or something so
the sunday before was when she told me
to stop doing blow
wow
i stopped doing blow maybe
three or four days before marilyn died
like that weekend i went to jersey
maryland died on a wednesday
i went to jersey on a thursday night
and thursday i went back to my my hotel
room and i didn't know why i was staying
at a different hotel
and i was gonna see a lot of weird
people
and i thought something cute was going
to happen
like you have a gut feeling in your
stomach so when i went there thursday
night
my friend picked me up drove me there i
smoked a joint with her outside she left
and i just took a shower
and i was mild matted it had started in
l.a the night before
marilyn had told me that sunday
so that
thursday i didn't get high
then that friday i thought about getting
i but something i didn't want to be high
because the show was saturday night
i was doing a benefit
for cops and hoboken and i was doing the
high school the flip the basketball team
they get jerseys that's great
so the one show was at six nil was at
nine perfect so friday night i said you
know what
i'm not gonna smoke coke tonight
and about two i wanted to get high i was
like oh i can make a call i'm like let
me just go to bed i was staying in the
sea caucus so it was away from everybody
that's why i didn't trust it
then that saturday i did the benefit for
the cops
and then i went to the high school thing
and at the high school thing one of my
buddies yelled something stupid in the
audience
about like a robbery or something
and i could see how [ __ ] coked up he
was like he couldn't even control
himself like he was john and she was the
bottom of a basement and i looked at him
and i go you know what
if that's what i look like snorting coke
i'm not snorting coke tonight
so when i got off that plane on sunday
when marilyn died that saturday that's
when she died that sadly and they were
going to bury her wednesday
and uh the wake was two the wake was
wednesday everything was one it wasn't
even awake
yeah i just wanted to go to the church
yeah we all went to the church so they
buried on a wednesday because they used
to go to kenpo karate thing you're right
wednesday was when we [ __ ] buried it
we went to the church and then we did
the thing at the comedy store that night
yeah so by the time i got to the comedy
store i was six nights clean with no
blow
so i got there sunday night i didn't do
blow on purpose or just by just the way
things worked out just the way
things worked themselves out
right and then
so i got back that sunday and i didn't
do blow marilyn had died and i don't
know something just didn't hit me right
the way she told me
i won't do bloat on monday monday was
always my night okay i love getting
blasted on monday nights i had everyone
left at the house
my buddy had sent me a little bit of
[ __ ] hair and i had some heroin one
and i'm like you know what [ __ ] i didn't
get high for a few days i feel good
tomorrow nights tonight i'll do a little
heroin
a little [ __ ] blow
couldn't get myself to do it i got a
call to do a movie
and the people call like in the morning
and they say you're interested and i go
[ __ ] yeah i did the table read
i've been bugging the [ __ ] people for
18 months now you [ __ ] call me and
like there's only a problem it's not
going to be a big budget movie you're
probably going to get 100 hours a day
but you're going to work 20 days you're
all right we thought i go [ __ ] yeah
and they said here's the other problem
there's no days off
except the thursday for thanksgiving
i said okay
and they said in something else
we know about your problem
so do not agree to this movie unless you
control it and i'll tell you why
because the movie's getting shot in one
room
so everybody is in every scene
it's not like lee's not going to come
until 10 because he pours coffee they
either shoot one half of the room or the
other half of the room that's the way
the whole movie was wow the whole movie
was shot in one room that's why i was so
cheap to make
so you couldn't miss so the guy goes we
understand your dilemma
we sympathize with you the guy was
really nice
and then i called somebody else and i go
hey man this guy just offered me this
and this is what they said to me he goes
joey you know people know yeah this is a
quick movie and they can't risk
you being [ __ ] high and not showing
up or showing up 30 minutes late right
so i thought about i thought how
embarrassing that was yeah that's
something you'd have to mention that to
me yeah
that if you take this movie you can't
[ __ ] get high
and i said you know what
just because somebody knows i'm gonna
[ __ ] these [ __ ] up the ass
i'm not gonna get high
i'm gonna do this wow so it was like
rehab it was like
the lord working in mysterious ways
because you were already clean for a
while i had five days clean or six days
clean and the night that i went to the
comedy store and caused all that problem
there was no night i wanted to get
higher more than that night
but i felt so bad i was so overwhelmed
with anger yeah but like oh the coat
would just take me somewhere else and i
didn't get high that night and then that
thursday
that i was gonna start shooting that
friday and when did superbad happen
super bad happened
that
week
super bad in fact i hugged super bad
today what a week and i told my wife i
go hey uh
this week because we've had super bad
for a [ __ ] seven
years and he goes how do you remember
that oh marilyn died today
so it was either last night or the night
before
when
dj died first yeah we had a siamese cat
that was [ __ ] beautiful
that was their brother that was super
bad's brother and those two girls a
sister
and he played with lulu he was always
kitten mates with lulu
and evie was always kid mates with super
bad so the one that i loved the most out
of that litter was dj
dj was jimmy jr
and jimmy jr at that small size
would pick up a tennis ball with his
teeth
and bring it to you it was [ __ ]
genius he was a kitten wow he was four
weeks he would pick up that little
[ __ ] thing and he would jump up in
the air try to jump and he'd spin around
he'd fall over he was just a goofball
that was grown
but he was a genius i come out and i'm
gonna go dj
dj and he'd [ __ ] come running
running come running and you pet him and
he purr and his sister would come over
and none of them will let you touch the
only dj
but super bad would always stand in the
corner out of all his cats
he was the farthest my wife tried to
befriend him [ __ ] you
i tried to befriend him [ __ ] he would
run and he would take dj and make him
climb up the tree
to hunt the the birds and the [ __ ]
garage and i used to hate him
i go so this [ __ ] don't come to
me
he don't have my food he won't pan then
he takes this guy into bad influence and
if he does something to dj i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill him
like i started not liking this [ __ ]
super bad cat i'm like i don't [ __ ]
like this [ __ ]
i would go out there and dj and
sometimes he would take a little longer
and also he'd come back black with the
other [ __ ] cat they were somewhere
where they weren't supposed to be and i
go where [ __ ] stupid bad whatever had
you i didn't call him super bad then i
just called him my shitty oh
or something [ __ ] or something
and then one day i'm like super bad you
bad [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
here
so when all that went down that week i
was sober
i don't even know maybe like a day
who the [ __ ] knows yes because it was
before i went to new york because when i
was in new york i kept calling the house
going how are the cats it was right
around that week when
i came home
and i
had a package
i had a package
and that was probably the last time i
started it was before i went to new york
thank you for bringing that up it was
that wednesday
because i came home with a [ __ ]
package and a half i did like somebody's
gig on a wednesday you know seven years
ago on wednesday night
there were eight gigs you could do yeah
you know uh fly had the latin castle
latina
and this guy so i would just go out and
pick up 160 bucks and
go to my boys and spend 60 and get this
the package supreme yeah you know [ __ ]
the taco i was getting the burrito
supreme on wednesday night
and as i [ __ ] now usually whenever i
did the blow in the garage
i would do a little bit and then run
upstairs
and terry would be out cold
so it would just be me and the cats i'd
stay in the bathroom i jerk off
i'd do a couple more lines i'd come a
little bit i get paranoid then i go out
there and walk down the computer
well this particular night when i walked
in terry's light was on
i'm like oh [ __ ]
so she comes down she said before you
open the door
dj's in there he's dying and so is super
bad i just don't want him to die outside
and i was like hey you [ __ ] what are
you talking about and she goes their
legs roll up
that means the anemic or something when
they have the anemia
and i [ __ ] run inside and i [ __ ]
they both just like you know they're
barely alive you know and i
start pissing and doing the blowing then
i tell to go to sleep you know and i
start doing the blow and
i would go in there every 20 minutes and
i'd do a line and i pet the little ones
dj
i think i reached for superbad a couple
times like you little [ __ ] who's
the boss no [ __ ] you know
and i did a bunch of coke and went to
sleep and that night she woke me up like
at 6 30 in the morning she goes just to
let you know dj's dead
and i looked like i just closed the door
and i go [ __ ] it but i go no
i can't have two cats die up here and i
got up and i got on my hands and knees
and pet him
and i prayed to god i prayed the [ __ ]
every god i knew to please save this
[ __ ] i couldn't let him die in
my house i'm not gonna keep him
i'm gonna [ __ ] keep this guy
you know and i went to get the oatmeal
cookies and as i was sitting there
giving him
crumpled up oatmeal cookies that's the
only thing he would eat he would barely
just take his mouth and he he was just
that's it a little bit of water put
water in my finger and he'll lick my
finger
and it was the weirdest thing because i
thought about it
how if i wouldn't i knew i wanted to
quit the blow
i knew that marilyn had already read me
the [ __ ] ride at
i knew this i knew it had to stop i knew
that i was doing heroin i knew that the
back of my neck was hurting at night i
always get shocks in the back of my neck
like those people that jolt like i was
getting shocked
my spine was hurting a little bit
towards the end of the night my spine
would hurt in bed
it wasn't gonna be good this was not
gonna end good guys
so something had to change
and the first thing i thought about when
i was in the floor giving him the
cookies was
i brought that poison into this [ __ ]
house
let's face it let's be [ __ ] honest
with everybody here this cat was on
the fence
and me bringing that imbalance
that torment that impurity into that
house
took him over the [ __ ] top
that's my thinking that was my thinking
at that time
and i said you know what while this cat
is rehabbing i'm not gonna bring that
[ __ ] up here
and that was the first time i really
believed myself wow like usually you
tell yourself come on i'm going to the
gym i'm going to lose 80 pounds [ __ ]
that i'm going to eat this cake like i
believed it like i was like it's not
he's not gonna die
so i have to snort coke
somewhere else
better yet i'll still come over here
with the coke in my system
i won't snort and that's when i said you
know what if this [ __ ] animal lives
i'll never do cocaine again
whether the guy's running the show it
could be a chinese guy
buddha it could be [ __ ] farrakhan's
nephew or some big fat black guy it
could be an italian looking
[ __ ] with a beard who's ever
running the show i'm making you this
promise as a man
that you know what i've done blow for 30
years
i'm 44 years old john gotti was 45 when
he took over the gambinos maybe if i
[ __ ] stop doing coke right now
something good will happen in my life
so if you could help me god and save
this cat i'll never do coke again
and i remember walking out of the
bathroom and really believing that like
really [ __ ] believing like all the
times i said that's it that's the last
line you know that time there when i
walked out of that bathroom and it was
scary how much i believed it
that i was ready to go out and do coke
wow do you follow me the line i tread
and also in the movie came awesome
maryland's weight came austin all these
tough things got thrown at me boom boom
boom detested how bad do you want it and
it was 10 days of hell plus this movie
and i said you know what this is what
i'm made of
this is what i'm made of once i get a
call from the producer and he's telling
me we know about your drug problem
you're going to be like michael this guy
you're going to be just like those
people
when people mention your name they're
going to go he's great but
the last time on the set he was eating
pills and falling asleep in his trailer
and we can wake him up one morning and
that's going to be the decisive thing
all you need is one voice against you at
every [ __ ] one of those things and
you're going to lose 50 of the jobs plus
your credibility for what to do coke
something that's already been done for
20 [ __ ] years i couldn't get no more
mileage out of it i got my dick sucked i
got coke blown in my ass with a straw
coke rocks in my peel i had robbed my
friends i robbed my family i lost my
dignity i went to prison over it how
much more [ __ ] blow could i [ __ ]
do
what is the purpose of this where is it
gonna go
and i believed myself that i was [ __ ]
done with the coke and that was it and
that cat lived
so this morning when i remember maryland
i picked him up and i hugged him he
jumped on me and ever since that day a
good friend of mine uh what's the the
red-headed comedian at the store older
guy hung out with kenneth and those guys
shows up once a year with jimmy schubert
one day we were shooting a short film he
was telling me that
when he was in college he had taken a
class a psychology class and and the
semester they studied cats and he was
overwhelmed about what he found out
about cats that they had a ton of
gratitude
that they showed gratitude and i thought
it was he was i looked at him like all
right whatever
and from superbad i'm telling you that
every day
after that he always gave me a little
bit extra attention
till this day terrios says get your
stinky cat out of here because everybody
knows that's my [ __ ] cat
he knows i made that promise that's why
i love him as much as i do because he
knows
he knows every day i was in that room
with him on my hands and knees giving
them those oatmeal cookies
and now he would look at me and just
want to say you know what let me die
yeah he would that's what he was saying
just let me die dog i don't need this
[ __ ] i'm on that jungle with [ __ ]
fleas
i got my sister chasing me with her
stinky [ __ ] ass
and i got both girls and i got super bad
today that's correct and then my
favorite pack i don't know and demi and
harry are tight
i love demi and harry they're not doing
harry two yeah but those three have
always stolen my heart but it's funny
because super bad bugs you like every
like at least once when i'm over there
superman i'm gonna kick you
super bad always attacks harry but it's
funny because i picked up demi
ally
and harry were all kittens
at the same time they were from
different moms
but they were all on that they all have
the same father
ali
harry and [ __ ]
jimmy all have the same father
wow they were well demi and harry are
brothers yeah yeah ally's their sister
but from a different chick that was in
the yard a gold beautiful siamese of
pretty eyes if you look at ali she's
beautiful she just gained weight no
later years
but she's [ __ ] beautiful you know
what i'm saying she's like [ __ ] you
know
and he checked now
what's going on hey you got a woman
yeah it's all right
what's this all right like shaving it
off like henry hill
it's all right
that story is just amazing because to me
that story's just about love and that's
how god works in mysterious no hugs no
i never looked back i never ever ever
have looked back in a while
i want to do a line i know that if i
broke that promise
it would be a man promise it's nothing
to do with god or it's it's a day that
you just wake up and make a promise to
yourself and every day that i live from
that promise
it just makes me stronger because i made
that promise is that much stronger i
stuck to it well look how beautiful your
life is now yeah and it's amazing that
night all that promise
opened up so many [ __ ] opportunities
you know
it's really if you told me this 10 years
ago i told you you're crazy
what's up with you [ __ ] are you
going to make a promise not to eat
edibles no more no because you wouldn't
let me do it but like you did cook for
what like 30 years something like that
how many years do you think you were you
you enjoyed it
because it seemed like at the end you
would be like sick of it i think the
first 10 years i really enjoyed the so
20 years 90 yeah
god it just became a part of my life it
was like all right this is what you
wanted
we're going to give it to you yeah
and every opportunity you have
two days into it somebody's going to
show up recover
i always knew where to get go
i could find coke and a small city in a
big city at a bar
at a restaurant at a [ __ ] toilet
i could find cocaine
and within two days i could find who was
selling pounds wow and i knew how i
could rob them already so i got all
these options thrown at me it was just
it was one of the worst situations ever
it was like somebody threw a curse on me
you wanna do blow okay we're gonna let
you do blow you're gonna do some [ __ ]
blow though
yeah that's crazy you said that at the
beginning of the podcast be careful what
you wish for
that's crazy sometimes you let's give
some shout outs here lisa yeah why are
you looking at me like a [ __ ] cause
you got me hot i gave you a beautiful
shirt from new zealand oh yeah my main
man mel prior sent that he sent two
t-shirts
he sent some candy from my wife that
sounds [ __ ] up or whatever
and he sent uh
a beautiful teddy bear for my daughter
when i thank them all the way from
[ __ ] new zealand their beautiful
shirts beautiful designs duncan mcgregor
you bad [ __ ]
caesar flores
john michaels
johnny fun buckets
gevork kevin bauyan
whatever the hell then the divorce kevin
by jan i don't know what the [ __ ]
going on there okay york and then bob
leon how did kevin come into this
[ __ ] thing and my main man tyler
perceva whatever
you're a bad [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying
tell me about the evolution of the cd
how long have you been has this been in
the works
for since i got started i would say
pretty much what can you use pretty much
it's 14 years
that's why your first album is always
the best any band your first time is
always the best because they've been
working
at that for eight nine years that's the
sound they've been perfecting so yeah
that's what and i always thought
somebody was going to come along and put
me on tv and go here's your special and
i thought the machine would make it
happen whatever it is
and that never happened you know what i
mean and that's what i love about
podcasting and your help and lee's help
and we got this thing out there now i
can show the world like this what i do
this is what i do it's amazing what the
expectation is of people what my
expectation was when i got here
what my expectation was of each movement
that i made because
okay
i i don't know how to describe him lee's
world
i know how to describe in the criminal
element i know i know that
uh you know let's say you you sell coke
right you sell coke every [ __ ] day
and you sell a certain amount
i don't even know how to break this
[ __ ] down
and then every once in a while you make
a move you sell two kilos to somebody
end up making 35 000
or something like that you know and and
now what do you do with that 35 000 is
the main thing
do you throw it under your [ __ ]
carpet and go out every night and buy
clubs and right pick up checks or
whatever or do you buy a business to get
yourself out of the predicament you're
in
so you don't have to sell blow no more
the same thing happens with this career
i always thought that once you did
something you were going to have all
this [ __ ] to happen and a wise man told
me that
everything in this city happens in
layers
yeah you might do this cd it's 2013.
what year was it 2014 and 2017 some guys
putting together a show
like a reality show and listen you're
like why am i in here
i bought your cd i heard about it from a
friend of mine and
i've been laughing i've taken on trips i
bought it for 10 of my friends right you
are the funniest man in the world and
you're like
i made no money nobody ever said nothing
to me
nobody ever called me and now you're
offering me 11 episodes on a reality
show right this is what they do i was
going through a truck stop and i seen
your cd and i bought it
whatever the [ __ ] it's it layers yep and
you don't know when that
investment is gonna make a dividend
it but you're not gonna know unless you
make the investment and you make it
correctly yep
so
if you
have uh you're also on a gabriel show
yep two weeks ago okay
you know
little things become big things little
things are what you make them i'm sure
you wanted an hbo special right sure but
for right now gabriel glacier amazing
[ __ ] he's a he's the same watch
you do a saint phone love you the same
way everybody in this room is falling in
love with you
and he puts you on his tv show it's
going to be viewed by a million million
people yeah i can't thank them enough so
now your decision is what you do next
with this move you just got a movement
on your lap yep do you [ __ ] sit at
home and dance do you go on the [ __ ]
road that's it do you now you're gonna
sell this cd you're gonna push dcd to
give three that was only a three four
minute set right so it's amazing how
things all happen come together things
are coming together yeah absolutely
sometimes you listen man for someone
like steve brown i bumped into him with
his sweetheart he's the best i'm gonna
contact him get him on the podcast
steve's a sweetheart guy things happen
for me that tv show on the air when i
saw that happen i knew that i was one
step closer absolutely okay because one
of your friends are making this is how
you have to look at it for sure i do
about a month six weeks ago you and i
had a conversation on the way home we
stopped in the 7-eleven yeah you didn't
feel when things were moving along and i
went home that night and giggled
and i did something i never [ __ ] do
because i learned a very important
lesson
i woke my wife up wow i told her exactly
what happened wow i said tonight she
goes what's my idol you know
when i was driving
steve home
he we pulled over 7-11 he was frustrated
i felt this frustration
and the whole time i'm feeling his
frustration i'm laughing inside because
it reminded me of somebody
and steve was a gentleman about it when
i used to get frustrated over a role or
what wasn't happening for me why i
wasn't going to montreal
why
why why i have a booking agent why
didn't i have ca why is nothing
happening why is nothing happening
at the same time there was movement and
i'd go home and yell at the cats or
i'd call somebody tell me go [ __ ]
themselves or whatever and she'd say all
this for nothing
over this if it's going to happen it's
going to happen you're working or the
results are coming you know and i
remember saying what the [ __ ] are you
talking about what'd you get down good
morning america
you know what the [ __ ] right the more
angry you get the more yeah yeah yeah
somebody's trying to show your love and
it's amazing and i told you it's gonna
be fine
i know so many people who have been here
15 years
and they're still where they are
when you see a man
i'm still trying to get into the comedy
store i'm putting my tape together you
know oh god
you could have jumped into an ocean swam
around the world like diane nyad and
made a bigger name for yourself yep
you're over here still fighting that
battle and because of that it's not
going to let you grow vinnie curl
won't [ __ ] talk to me
because a couple weeks ago he showed up
at the store and he kept asking me who
do i talk to to get spots
vinnie
i don't know i just got here myself
right
who would put me up tonight
i don't know
talk to the people in the [ __ ] booth
yeah talk to the guy well i didn't they
say i gotta get a reference when you
give me a reference i go vinnie i don't
know about him right
you know
i'm a [ __ ] guest
this belongs to youth
i'm a guest and if i'm a guest
you're a [ __ ] stranger yeah because i
[ __ ] put my well my name is on the
[ __ ] wall yeah because you made a
reclusive i don't know what happened
right him and mitzi i don't know what
the [ __ ] happened but but it's amazing
that he was still mad about the store
right like i got to talk to paul you
know and you could by this conversation
you could have done 15 spots at the
heart sure if you really really want to
do comedy
by all this there's always a stage all
this negativity you're not getting on
stage there's a million stages all right
they don't give you spots there
jay masala is a [ __ ] punk he won't
give me spots here what about the improv
bud freeman so nobody gives you a spot
right there you're owing three
maybe somebody's trying to tell you
something
when you own [ __ ] three i was one in
two i just spots at the end problem with
the comedy store last time you didn't
like me fine right today's a different
[ __ ] story but 15 years ago they
didn't like me and i understood it right
you know some people like cream and
their coffee that's it some people like
black coffee not to get you that's what
i love about comedy though that's just a
flavor for everybody i took my wife to
that place yesterday you recommend it
which one mambo oh what did you think
i gave it a nine a nine
i always get so nervous when i recommend
food to you [ __ ] mambo platter what's
mambo it's a beautiful cuban
20 15 minutes on me
that's why you should throw kettlebells
what did you get
i got the mambo platter
i got the encelada
which is avocado salad with lettuce and
raw onions oh nice vinegar on top jesus
christ i didn't order no bread no butter
yep all right i got the combo platter
which is fried bananas paprinas cuban
empanadas which i forgot what the [ __ ]
they look like [ __ ] all this [ __ ] you
get out of here
and sausage
spanish sausage with some crackers and
[ __ ]
opened up with that and then we got uh
the cuban pork oh i gave it a s8
it's not what we're used to it's not
very traditional but i get it right
but what what stole my soul was the uh
the ground beef the picalillo with the
white rice my wife got that it was off
the [ __ ] chain with some fried
bananas
we went all out we split the [ __ ]
floor i'm glad you liked it that makes
it tremendous tremendous i get way
better i feel like i'm vouching for
somebody
yeah i'm like oh god what place and i'm
going to roll it
way better than that place in burbank oh
wow way better well
it's fresh
it's new you could tell that they played
manchester united's family there it's a
family three generations they're always
watching you they come over
oh i didn't know that jersey yeah i
talked to a kid oh i knew that because i
started talking and i started dropping
he goes how's your meal in bengal that
means it showed up with a big dick and
angry guy looked at me like what that's
right [ __ ] you guys i put you
in check the fried bananas were so good
right that's what i love the most
perfect how do you make good fried
bananas
they're just perfect they're not greasy
they're not hot
they're sort of sticky you know a little
sticky
they're [ __ ] delicious it was just
delicious the potato balls were [ __ ]
[ __ ] portos and that [ __ ] really the
better than porto's oh jesus i'm so glad
the croquetas were delicious two
croquettes jay davis turned me on to
that the [ __ ] cuban food
had the meat in the middle but the
outside was corn flakes
like the way they make the chewies and
chewies in houston and austin they make
the elvis chicken on wednesday nights
good googly moogly good googly moogly
and they put [ __ ] cornflakes on that
[ __ ]
sounds delicious oh i could go for a
chewy sour cream and chicken enchilada
right now that's a special on mondays
with a swirl margarita and some chips
and [ __ ] queso like a [ __ ]
oh lee you have no idea you'd be
sweating profusely here i am your shirt
would be open your head would be on fire
you'd have a nap and you'd be hitting it
like the [ __ ] i don't even know like
who
you excited bro you look good you got
the mustache the new [ __ ]
you look like the guy that hung out with
[ __ ] travolta
you're happy now you're a pig that guy
you're a pig so great that was a [ __ ]
crazy movie so good it's crazy i was
thinking because i've
been working with steve for almost a
year close to it and like i was i
thought to myself a few weeks ago
that basically where he is now is where
you were almost
when i met you
and from your lips to god's ears maybe
like maybe a few years ahead could make
a little bit more touring
but
it was right at the beginning
and then i know you were frustrated and
you you signed up to be a car dealer
so that's what i was doing a couple
weeks ago i was looking at jobs like
what else could i do but now it seems to
be lining up
and you gave me that great pep talk you
remember i wasn't happy with stuff i was
recording you were like just get it out
there and that's been the lesson
that god the universe whatever you don't
need to be perfect to be loved just get
something out there
give them a little taste and let it
build it doesn't need to be perfect
right out of the gates
but i think you did a great job on this
lee i can't thank you enough i'm proud
of it this is the first thing i've done
where i want everybody to listen to it i
want them to check it out i go this is
it captured that moment it captured what
it was like for a night yeah but me
headlining a club it's it's kind of
scary not scary but it's nerve-wracking
when you're gonna
show something
for me when i'm showing anyone work i
did for them so i'm glad you like it and
i'm i'm glad already said he liked it so
it's uh yeah especially for comedians
because i get asked a lot if i want to
do comedy and i just i don't think i'm
anywhere i it's just not for me
but i've always
enjoyed it oh i can't do that right now
um
but
i don't like i don't want people
complain a lot about editors for
specials or whatever i just i don't want
i don't want to be a you can make it an
issue you could make a killing if that's
what you wanted to do you can make a
killing you got to know comedy to cut it
yeah and very few people i know that
comic listen when those people ask me if
i want to do a special and i asked the
director to come see me at the ice house
and he said to send me a tape
i knew the guy wasn't real i was done
yeah i was done right there because that
was
that's how a real guy sees it then after
he goes to see me
then he'll come in with a camera tape
and take it back to his office
right
and we'll see the differences but at
first before you agree to sign on with
me come see me you'd be crazy if you're
a director wouldn't you and you'd say i
got a horror script for you lisa yeah
first of all i don't know you joey
who are you well uh steve simone wrote
he wrote the office
okay i'm gonna sign on really you didn't
even look at the [ __ ] script yep so
that's how i knew when this guy said to
me yeah
i have plans really you have plans for
all four [ __ ] shows
and thursday and the podcast on
wednesday awful you're a busy [ __ ]
guy
but you're sitting here eating [ __ ]
lunch with grease on your fingers trying
to shake my hand and wiping your [ __ ]
fingers
and that's how you know if somebody's
real somebody's not well you'll go watch
it perform yep and he'll say one thing
to you listen man
if you get advice from if you bomb and
you get advice from lee and you're gonna
advise him a [ __ ] 10-year comic
you're gonna get two different things
and you're gonna think lee's crazy but
lee's gonna tell you one thing that
makes sense
because in the end of the day he's an
audience member yes
he's an audience number so every time i
go out with lee
i wouldn't do this to anybody else i go
lee what'd you think yeah and he'll tell
me very honestly what he thinks i didn't
like this
this needs work
this is okay that was funny when did you
write that yeah ask me where did you
write that why did you write that what
made you think of that
and that right there those questions
make sure he wants to know oh i got that
i'll put that somewhere else because you
told me that you got you know yes and
that's what people do any level
you can't
do a ten thousand dollar performance a
ten thousand dollar job with a ten
dollar performance right you gotta it
shows it shows at the end of the day
and with kami rogan called the other day
he said he asked about specials when we
were talking
and they said he went to a taping that
the production team was [ __ ]
and he goes you could tell that the
production team were like a cut
like it was the
c team
gotcha like they had got the c team
because they didn't want to pay or
something like that you know and you
could see the see the difference the
difference is you know whatever the
camera's listening to cameras the camera
everybody's selling you the red dot
where is it the right camera yeah the
rake i got a red camera cause 32 000
we'll shoot your special deal there's
nothing nothing everybody's got that
[ __ ] the same camera right yeah and i
got a friend who cost 31 000 so you got
beat [ __ ]
what's up lisa yeah you bad [ __ ]
nothing how you really look what's on
the plans this week what are your plans
so your wife moved yeah she's up here
now did you go over that today no no no
i was [ __ ] tired what are you waiting
for she got food in the refrigerator no
not yet i think she had food she's
making tacos dorado on wednesday nice
what what a taco's dorado for the people
at home they're uh she takes chicken and
mashed potatoes and cheese i think and
rolls it up and then she deep fries that
and it's just
it's a little bit of a cheat but it's
gonna be amazing calories on it a
thousand i don't know like
i think she gave me four last time how
many [ __ ] how was he gonna do the
elliptical
i don't know i did it this weekend i was
proud of myself at the at the the hotel
yeah how long did you do it for uh one
day i did it for 35 one day after an
hour oh the same elliptical oh yeah it
is [ __ ] up it's a different spot
there's a different stride oh it's
[ __ ] up when you go to a hotel
and at least trying listen if you try
that's better listen every hotel has
three or four yoga mats yeah every hotel
has dumbbells you know there's something
you could do there's always something
what i do when i check in is i go i
check my luggage i take a walk around
the hotel but i go look at the gym
i check myself into the gym i go see
what they got and i go okay i make a
mental note then i go upstairs and i
make some things i could do
plus i go on youtube and i just look for
like [ __ ] stupid
exercise and there's always [ __ ] on
there that you know there's always a
five foot pool i can do a lot of damage
in a five foot pool you can run inside
the pool yeah it's true 30 minutes of
running inside the pool when you walk
out of there your body's [ __ ]
vibrating
you jump in a pool do 10 sets of [ __ ]
50 jump up and down see what happens
here next day
you do that for [ __ ] six weeks see
what happens to you you slam dunking
lisa you'll be like [ __ ] spud webb
oh my goodness what's up dog what are
you gonna do after this what are you
gonna eat at the house what do you got i
got nothing because i just got back so
you mean to tell me you're gonna go home
and sit there like [ __ ] no i'm gonna
get something i've been thinking about
it during the podcast
what are you thinking about in my heart
i want jack in the box but i'm not gonna
do that no you can't do that so what are
you going to sell for uh either subway
or uh maybe try to find a place where i
could get like some chicken teriyaki you
already have subways
every japanese person this village is
[ __ ] shut down for the night no
there's nothing they're at home playing
[ __ ] making incense i was worried i
was like should i go to a different
subway so they don't recognize me
getting two subs in one day
trust me you won't be the only guy i
know you fit the [ __ ] characteristics
the guys are planning on shooting the
president
they eat two subway sandwiches a day and
they don't talk much
they [ __ ] don't like dogs
i don't know [ __ ] i was i was trying not
to eat but what did you eat for lunch at
this subway today pepperoni pepperoni
with white bread
no wheat bread and what else you put on
the pepperoni a little bit of shredded
cheese a bunch of oregano and crushed
red pepper you said i got the one
it's like a little mini pizza hey it's
pepperoni from subway which isn't really
pepperoni it's like a turkey that nobody
wants for thanksgiving
they look at and they go [ __ ] no
it's like that that one slave and
[ __ ]
12 years of slave but the other one
[ __ ] uh
apocalypto that's another book oh my god
how do you different pepperoni
like a weak black guy you showed up with
glasses and [ __ ] they would just slap
you and make your wife suck that dick
they were [ __ ] terrible white people
terrible
what's up i normally get bored's head
pepperoni but
they don't have boys they're not not a
subway they're groceries yeah yeah it's
subway that's not boys that's turkeys
they don't want i know but that can't
the treasures are [ __ ] up they got
eyeballs missing they got malaria they
got colds right and they look at them in
the face and they go this guy ain't
gonna work out for him
send them to the pepperoni factory and
they slice their head off they let the
blood drip all over the feathers and
they throw it to a [ __ ] grinder
and they look at it and it looks orange
with blood i think oh no no no fill her
in put some rice
put some [ __ ] spicy
get the italian to help you out and they
spice that [ __ ]
they put food coloring they spray paint
it and then you walk in and get a
[ __ ] pepperoni sandwich you [ __ ] see
i'm saying
you're the wheel of confusion you're
just adding
what are you laughing it's better than
that it's better than the the new like
fritos pizza or listen not your cheese
that's why i love you to death you don't
eat that
little [ __ ] hitler and the other one
you were eating the cheese sticks you
were sitting at home rubbing yourself
with those cinnamon sticks [ __ ]
from where my source is from little
cheeses my sources they have cinnamon
sticks whatever the [ __ ] you were
getting some sticks look at it you know
taco bell has good cinnamon stuff like
punches no [ __ ] yeah those are good i
bet you were the first one online at 11.
yeah
white shoes huh [ __ ] yeah with white
shoes on all probably you said taco bell
ain't bad dog
late night those uh
the soft tacos weren't bad the hard
tacos weren't bad the hard tacos off the
chain the little ones best taco
best taco out there fat man alert fat
man alert
best taco out there if you want to die
of a heart attack
at 52 is the big taco from jack in the
box they ain't [ __ ] around jack oh
those are so bad cause they keep frying
oh they deep frying they're leaking they
put american cheese in it oh yeah and
you eat that before you get the goods ah
like you might as well get that and a
double order of the [ __ ] fish and
chips
god knows what you're eating you're
eating frog and
fish and [ __ ] smelts
it's the feast of 19 fishes
you're eating [ __ ] and everything
seashells and [ __ ]
sea horses and manta rays
those things that jump on the water
manta rays i don't [ __ ] know anymore
what am i
anyway what's up with you lee everything
all right you got plans for the weekend
what do you got cracker lacking i got
nothing come on i don't know
it's a big [ __ ] night tonight man i'm
very proud of steve simon 14 years out
here 10 years busting it
put it together finally he'd been
procrastinating for like two and a half
years and i'm sitting there looking at
pictures of [ __ ] richard pryor crying
thinking about fat james did you put him
in the cup did you mention him
[ __ ] i haven't got the hard ones
printed up put it he'll get a shout out
he's got a birthday coming out sure a
little picture of fat jams wiping his
feet when he got home with a sandwich in
one hand picking his toenail with the
other
wait are you gonna mention him as fat
james that was his that was a strange
name what do you want to call everybody
gustavo james james
the [ __ ] you don't want to call nobody
by that [ __ ] slave name
i don't want to call you whatever your
real name is lee [ __ ] whatever say
yeah
i'll call you the flying jew that's your
street name
people don't give a fat james is a
[ __ ] up street name well that's what
happens they couldn't call him skinny
james
it just wouldn't fit you know what i'm
saying it was him it was fat james and
james painter and everybody go which
james and people started going no you
know fat james oh and that's how i got
it
flak fat james was a good man god bless
big heart
big heart he had a little whiff of like
[ __ ] romano cheese one when you
hugged them poor guy when you got close
to his neck you always got hungry
and you hugged them you're like man why
am i hungry and [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was allergic to
water he's probably up there laughing
right now [ __ ] you joey
that was that one time i did 400
push-ups and you came to the store and
hugged me that's why i swear one time
that one time i was booting from the
60-yard line
steve simone and she listen people let
me tell you let me tell you the
breakdown here
we canceled somebody tonight i could
have steve simone and i'll tell you why
out of all these [ __ ] mutts that are
around me in hollywood and all these
[ __ ] sports is that
claimed to do this this guy worked and
he suffers and he works hard and every
penny he puts away and he visits his
family
and he brings back gifts from my
daughter and people around him and his
family and he he goes to this church and
he [ __ ] hangs out with nuns and
smokes cigarettes
and they tell them names he gives them
names they're in the cia and he gives
them names
they pray for those names and
uh there's a lot of people out there you
people buy into all that [ __ ] and
they got no heart for nobody
this guy would pull over if there was a
pigeon in the middle of the street with
his wing [ __ ] up he'd stop traffic so
you guys spend your money on all this
[ __ ] first of all this guy's a
tremendous comedian
and he's coming up heavy [ __ ] duty
and you guys what are you gonna do
give this [ __ ] seed what's the name
of this [ __ ] thing remember this
remember this remember this right now
don't [ __ ] with me because i'm gonna be
tweeting it the next 24 [ __ ] hours
i'm giving out gifts
i'm giving i found the block of oak
cocaine it's got water on it
it still works if you're creative i'll
send out little pieces like the berlin
wall
you're gonna get some [ __ ] up emails
this week now i don't give a [ __ ] i'll
send it out if you [ __ ] make this
album number one i will send the [ __ ]
coke rock right to your house what you
do with it that's up to you you
understand me i'm wiping my hands i
don't want no drama you get in the
mailbox who send it to you i don't know
there's not gonna be a fingerprint on
there nothing it's gonna come unmarked
like a cable company in bulgaria
just nod sign it and run upstairs who
gives a [ __ ]
i'll put the link in the description
what link i want a cd yeah take care of
the [ __ ] guy all right this is a cd
you need to get thank you uh it's just a
status thing we need to prove to the
church we need to let these
[ __ ] know we're coming from
we're all [ __ ] the freak party
2015.
we patched over the other old names and
nemesis and all that [ __ ] so we're
really iraqi people
what do you want from me thank you that
was beautiful oh you're a good dude man
and all these people put out [ __ ] and
people this is the seed that you need to
get i'm gonna get 200 [ __ ] copies
alone and give them out the blind kids
remember this [ __ ]
remember me
what are you taking mama this week
i don't know oh i shouldn't tell you
this
oh [ __ ] it so you know the place where
we took the crepe class yeah she signed
us up for a steak cooking class which is
gonna be [ __ ] cool that's cool duck
fat potatoes
a little salad some steak what is that i
don't know i'm excited though all right
let me know so i could flatten you
inside
i could stick a [ __ ] grenade in your
[ __ ]
anti-freeze wire
don't forget to bring up one for papi
here oh the last time i brought you
crepes you yelled at me i ate one and
gave you the other one you brought me
some fruit crepe how about plain and ham
and cheese the hamburger cheese is
delicious the cheese is melted but the
other one plain i thought it's like give
me a plain piece of bread
i ate the burger but i brought you two
buns
i may have a pickle on the floor in the
car
oh my god i love these monday night
podcasts it brings out the best of me i
love it
the live ones out yeah well let's do it
listen where are you at this week steve
someone reno reno what club it's called
like the reno tahoe comedy club
at the underground yeah great guy are
you headlining yeah great [ __ ] club
if you're in reno in the bay area let me
tell you who's up there he's up there
i'm in san francisco felipe's at rooster
t feathers eating [ __ ]
uh whatever [ __ ]
oh my god
i'm gonna get [ __ ] pissed all over
it's like going to cvs to get a
prescription
every time i think of felipe's vegan
she's like a cvs you got a [ __ ]
prescription i just get agitated i walk
out of your blood pressure medication
i'm sorry i went off on that tangent on
[ __ ] felipe's vegan ways
but the bay area is hopping i'm at the
[ __ ] punch line in downtown san
francisco having a great time thursday
friday saturday my main man [ __ ] uh
steve simone
is at the reno underground my man wayne
friday and saturday one show friday to
one second exactly tremendous club
downstairs real cool real hip
wayne's a bad [ __ ] they got food
i think a chinese guy delivers on a
bicycle you get the food though like 20
minutes later delivered right to your
table
with a band-aid
what's better than that who's better
than [ __ ] you where you at this
weekend we had a steak cooking where you
at no i don't know that's not for a
while
what are you gonna do i don't have plans
how do you do not have plans you always
got [ __ ] plans i don't know i haven't
seen paul in a while so hey what are you
planning on doing you know bring over to
the cars and show the bosses
always normally lend you my cape
i would that'd be kind of cool will you
make love that way
might even see though
it's one of these to make love to her i
don't know where the cape i don't think
she'd let me yes she would what what is
this thing which she lets me
what is the [ __ ] look it's get a
little iffy if you don't really care
about it just letting you [ __ ] somebody
with a cape
you let them settle say what do you need
let them settle he said let's make some
love
and you go hold on i'm thirsty
you take like eight minutes no more no
less eight minutes
you come back with that [ __ ] cape and
just dance
even if there's no music imagine in your
head
just think it's whatever you know like
latin music or like what kind of
whatever whatever she's mexican yeah but
that's a mexican music santana
black magic woman
how would you dance a black magic woman
well the cape on yeah would you dance i
imagined it to be like a lot of hips
yeah so you come in your hip first [ __ ]
and you'd stick your hand in between
both knees
all right
and just flip it
just flip that leg over trust me
if you need it step up on her and lock
her one knee with your knees
but i don't know if this is jiu-jitsu or
sex [ __ ] this is sex this is [ __ ]
sex
and once she sees the cape before she
even says something
if you give them a chance to speak be
[ __ ] up
don't even give them a chance just come
right in put santana on and go right for
it and then boom you pick up the legs
split it and your dick is already out
you you you're naked with the cape on
there's no under clothes on it's just a
cape
you go out there and you rub that little
monkey with your little jew helmet and
just pop that [ __ ] in like a
savage
or
oh
or see she's listening she knows
she knows who's gonna lay some [ __ ]
pipe out of the old school way with a
cape on and [ __ ]
your buddy ryan actually just texted me
he says it's number two already get out
of here this is what i'm talking about
guys congratulations wow steve simone
number two on itunes only a couple more
people reaching out if you're live do me
the favor on a personal tip
i love you [ __ ] thank you very
much what were you saying [ __ ]
what do i think where are we going i
don't know no you know you're you're
telling me how to [ __ ] with a cape
yeah so now you rub your little helmet
and right there when she don't know
what's going on she's going to say you
take the cat and she's saying take the
cable you're just going to drop
and the cape's going to rise like a
parachute and that's the beauty of it
see you have no pyrotechnics we don't
have that in the budget right now but as
you're dropping you could throw those
little firecrackers you got those kids
the little poppers
the white ones so as you drop you throw
pop
the cake pops up and you're writing a
little monk walk
just licking that [ __ ] thing
right in there you get deep in that
[ __ ] [ __ ] when it swells you're
swallowing your mouth
you ever have that [ __ ] thing swell
in your mouth yeah and your tongue and
you can taste piss and other variable
things but you don't give a [ __ ] deep
you taste like all this [ __ ] but you
don't give a [ __ ] you just lick right
through it you get that skin and you can
feel that [ __ ] just swelling in your
mouth and it starts to give you that
like little juice and you're sucking
that [ __ ] you ain't even finger
banging yet you just you just
steve this is a lot of this is on the cd
right
because i always imagine the camera
pulls back and it's a group of 10 year
old kids
that's your show oh my god make room for
uncle joey a little [ __ ] with your lips
make those little noises
like you're reading like a popsicle
and you [ __ ] that lip and she's [ __ ]
dying you don't even have a finger yet
in her ass nothing you're picking her
ass up like
and you're threatening her [ __ ] with
the pinkies but you're threatening
you're just maneuvering the pinky just
to give a
side i'm telling you this is getting me
[ __ ] hot
i don't know about you [ __ ] but the k
you have to get you have to wear the
cape to do this is the cape the whole
time okay and right when she's ready to
pop boom you pop up slip that helmet in
there and take it to the next level like
a soldier that y'all lisa
and by the time she gets off you know
what you're gonna say to you
got into you and you're gonna go it's
the [ __ ] cape that's our real pimp's
roll
i gotta tell you everything i'm trying
to get pissed off i'm sorry i'm gonna
take this to grab the [ __ ] no i'm
gonna stare at it for twenty five
dollars it looks [ __ ] delicious
you know what people [ __ ] it you know me
on it optimization you want to be the
best at what you do you want your mind
to be sharp it all starts with alpha
brain plain and [ __ ] simple we could
sit here and go back and forth for weeks
alpha brain is where the [ __ ] it starts
you want focus you want energy you want
to think more clearly you want to look
at people and look right [ __ ] through
them and know this guy's a [ __ ]
jerk-off alpha brain and they got a
money-back guarantee we don't even want
the [ __ ] bills back if we don't say
happens happens if it don't happen then
we'll take the [ __ ] we'll send you
the money back that's on it right there
but don't end there they got some new
stuff all right the mci or 100 coconut
oil you add it to your smoothies weight
management for energy delicious trans
fat the fats are healthy for your brain
when people are [ __ ] with you you
know that [ __ ] when you're why because
you had the coconut mcp oil the other
thing that's [ __ ] kicking ass is the
pre-workout t-plus tremendous a couple
minutes before your workout you hit that
little lemonade flavor ba-boom you're
going to get great [ __ ] strength
you're going to make great gains when
you lift you're going to go from lifting
22 pounds to 85 pounds like [ __ ]
hercules and heat no steroids you
understand me that's what's going on do
me a favor go to honor.com go down look
at the kettlebells look at the [ __ ]
monkey bells look at the [ __ ] flying
saucers but most importantly look at the
supplements that's where on it [ __ ]
shines those supplements are tremendous
whether it's the new mood or the shroom
tech sensational [ __ ] product read up
on them but do me a favor go to the on
that box or go to joeydears.net and then
you click on the on that label go to the
honor and you press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h get 10 off and do yourself a
favor just stay on the stay on it
program they deliver it right to your
house every month you don't got to leave
you're going to text nobody you don't
give them your credit card you just
[ __ ] tell them one time send it every
month ship that [ __ ] it gets all taken
out of your credit card you have to do
dick right there you make your protein
smoothie in the morning you do backflips
what the [ __ ] you do on it's there for
you go to joeydears.net order a t-shirt
look at my tour dates whatever the [ __ ]
it is that you do go to the other box
and press in
yo zombo
c-h-u-r-c-h and get 10 percent off
number two my favorite people in the
world if you've been watching you've
been hitting me you know i'm hitting
this [ __ ] 86 cigar right there this
is what pimp smoke we ain't [ __ ]
around no more hit these things don't
stop there either you're thinking about
smoke quitting smoking january's coming
what are you going to give up what have
you [ __ ] done what the [ __ ] have you
done john lennon under 20. you don't
hear [ __ ] that song you don't hear
where this is christmas do you ever hear
this christmas no you don't hear it till
the 20th once you hear what this is
christmas you're done if you haven't
done dick that year you feel like
[ __ ] [ __ ] because every year john
lennon comes on on the 20th of december
he asks you so this is christmas what
the [ __ ] have you done you miserable
[ __ ] you know what you're gonna do
you're gonna quit smoking this year
that's you're gonna do you're gonna quit
smoking cigarettes you know you're gonna
do it you're gonna go to hillysigs.com
you gotta pick a cigarette 24 milligrams
it goes on to 16 it goes down to eight
then to zero you'll be off those [ __ ]
cancer sticks you'll be smoking vapor
living like a doctor you have more
endurance your dick will work who's
better than you you know you don't stink
no more you ever smell your [ __ ]
fingers you're [ __ ] wiping your ass
you got cigarette nicotine on your
fingers and you go home and you want to
touch people you filthy [ __ ] go to
hedysigs.com they also come in different
flavors go to haitistigs.com and press
in joey's church joey's church joey's
church apostrophe
no apostrophes joey's church and get wet
off 20 who's better than you not 10
percent but 20. they're in a jew in
america they'll give you that deal 36
said [ __ ] we'll push it 20 [ __ ] these
things taste tremendous they last longer
guaranteed 1200 [ __ ] puffs you think
one of those things you buy over the
count at 7-eleven from those [ __ ]
terrorists give you 1200 [ __ ] pumps
[ __ ] though go to 86.com
and get twenty percent off right now go
to joeydears.net go to hittie6.com what
do you put in the box joey's church boom
and get 20 off yeah i think you've
changed that one since we've had them
have you no that's [ __ ] tremendous i
think i got like two that i move around
a little bit you know what i'm saying
that the [ __ ] hooker smoked this one
the one night so god knows what's in the
holes
well you never had a pubic hand in your
mouth not an old man
what's the difference between you and
some old man
pubic hair falls out the chick eats it
what the [ __ ] lee you see what happens
tonight when you get stoned the show
goes to [ __ ] dead
steve simone out of all the people i
don't wish this too i wish you all the
luck in the world with this thank you
john i taped your stand-up revolution i
haven't watched it i was going to try to
watch it today but the baby was going
like just to tell you what i really
thought but i know what i i'm going to
think it was [ __ ] sensational are you
happy with it
i would i'm going to be happy when
gabe's going to tweet out the unedited
version
so i was just happy to be on there
what's the difference in time
they took ten minutes and cut it down to
five what do you expect that's it yeah
they did the best they could do
and a guy like use a storyteller yeah so
they cut out kind of hurt you know yeah
it hurts yeah i did one bit but we
learned we learned the valuable lesson
and that's the most important thing
absolutely and if you got on comedy
central one time you'll get on hbo the
next what's the type of [ __ ] you
are you know
that's how we do it here we look for the
next [ __ ] step [ __ ] behind or what
happened or what didn't happen it's what
the [ __ ] you gotta do tomorrow okay what
the [ __ ] you gotta do tomorrow what the
[ __ ] have you done cox doctor you flew
back today i give you kudos and you made
it tonight oh yeah i wasn't gonna miss
this that's because i love you lisa yeah
we don't [ __ ] around we take it to the
next local weed oh and the church what's
happening now
it's like i tell you this week i'll be
at the punch line next week i'll be a
hilly in portland the week after that
i'll be in [ __ ] helium
philly oh that's great my main man and
i'm gonna bring him a little [ __ ]
present from the bakery some italian
cookies maybe some [ __ ] philly
cheesecake whatever the [ __ ] cheese
steak
cheesecake cheese steak what are you
johnny menus all of a sudden
what the [ __ ] awesome you want to
interact here [ __ ] nobody asked
you to [ __ ] correct me
anyway
johnny man use those johnny menus i love
you guys stay black have a great [ __ ]
tuesday don't forget to tell your
friends to to stay black too and go [ __ ]
themselves i love you guys have a great
night steve throw him a kiss where you
at thank you joey uh reno this week the
album remember this i love you joey i
love you too thank you
what about you [ __ ] what's up buddy how
you doing my main man i'm good you're
gonna be all right time yeah i'm gonna
go home [ __ ] yeah you're as tough as
[ __ ] nails what i'd tell you was 10
milligrams it was not 10 milligrams at
least maybe the credit i've earned maybe
maybe two maybe maybe 12.
but i still love you you're a savage
buddy god damn it all right slight black
okay i forgot something okay
now the show's over uh don't forget just
go sign up at on it.com they have the
uh stay on it program or they send it
straight to your house use codeword
church to get ten percent off
if you go and also go to hit esigs.com
that's hit
esigs.com
better tasting longer lasting the proof
is in the vape they have e-cigarettes
and e-cigars use codeword joey's church
to get 20 off